is
members take their seats we've got a
long day ahead of us sooner we get going
JB
s
I also come to water
Tara recognizes the member from Auburn
representative Osborne was the house
adjourned from the session of May 4
2023. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye I suppose Nate
the eyes have it the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
guest chaplain Reverend Dennis C Brunell
interim Rector at St Paul's Episcopal
oh God you have given us this good land
for our heritage
we humbly ask you that we may always
prove ourselves to be a people mindful
of your favor
bless our state with honorable industry
sound learning and respect for each
other
save us from violence confusion and
Discord from pride and arrogance and
from every disrespectful way
defend our liberties and fashion into
one United people the many different
multitudes that have settled in this
Granite State
and do with the spirit of wisdom and
generosity Those whom we entrust the
authority of government especially the
legislature of New Hampshire
that they may enact such laws that may
bring True Justice and peace freedom and
dignity for all the citizens of New
Hampshire
in time of prosperity fill our hearts
with thankfulness
and in the day of trouble let our
willingness to honor each other Prevail
do you recognizes a member from Campton
representative Tommy who will lead us in
the chair now recognizes the murder from
Bristol representative Carol Brown who
[Music]
oh see can you see
by the dawn's early light
what's so proud
ly we hail
at the
twilight's lastly
whose broad stripes and bright stars
[Music]
fight
oh God
please streaming
and
rockets red glare The Palms
bursting in
air
Gabriel
through the night
that our flag was
there
[Music]
oh see does that star spangled by
Earth
[Music]
[Laughter]
home of the praise
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives hatch and Summers the
day important business Representatives
Bean Platt Saudi trottier verville vote
and wolf
these leaves will be granted and those
otherwise ordered by the house
I also attend to the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome John
farrelli and Chris Brown sons of
Representative Carol Brown Jennifer
Sylvester guest of Representative Hoyt
Lucas nearing guest of Representative
Bay Robert and Iris Siebert parents of
Representative Siebert Roy and Mary
Dennehy David Russell and Tom Aria
guests of the Wyndham delegation Hal
Stokes guest of Representatives luno and
miler fourth grade students from Pelham
Elementary School guests of
Representative a bear and 4th grade
students from Interlakes Elementary
School guest of Representative closure
they're with us in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
foreign
Kate Murray from Memorial remarks for
the former member from Newcastle
thank you Mr Speaker
David Borden served in New Hampshire
house for four terms from 2006 through
2012.
before coming to Concord David had a
life experiences which gave him
a broad perspective he was an infantry
medic a training officer in the Peace
Corps and a Community Development
specialist
he and his family formed Victoria
international corporation giving
hundreds of international cup
corporations
opportunities to improve their customer
service
David has always been oops David had
always been an environmentalist and
served on the New Hampshire Rivers
Council the Seacoast land trust and
sustainable Harvest International
David and Nancy Borden
became friends when I married and moved
to Newcastle in 1999 their home the
little red house with their large
extended family was always a fun place
to visit
many friends and neighbors added a warm
touch to many evenings on the shore of
the piscataqua while rocking on their
porch
when Nancy thought it would be a good
idea to have a small Cafe the entire
family got into the act and opened
Henry's named after Nancy's brother
it soon became a central meeting place
for meals in between visits to the
town's post office across the street now
called The Islander it is still adorning
newcastle's downtown district
our friendship took an interesting twist
when he and my late husband arogoda ran
for state representatives many an
afternoon was spent looking at maps of
Newcastle and Rye to organize their
canvassing
they started the tradition in our town
to go door-to-door with their literature
on bicycles
it was a happy sight to see them riding
through Rya Newcastle and always relying
on its background
for customer service I know David wrote
hundreds of thank you notes from those
visits that summer
in November of 2005 they were both
elected and we have canvassed on
bicycles in their honor ever since
David served on the science technology
and energy committee committee while in
the house and focused his efforts on
reducing energy consumption at the
municipality level
renewed renewable energy was always on
his mind and when biofuels became
available for heating homes he made sure
everybody was aware of its availability
additionally he was appointed to the New
New Hampshire storm Water Commission and
the agricultural energy Committee of the
National Conference of state legislators
by then house Speaker Terry narelli and
now to share with you the rest of the
story is my friend and colleague Kate
Murray
Dave Borden passed away Wednesday May
3rd 2023 he was born April 14 1936 and
raised on a Farm in Vermont as you heard
his fingerprints can be found all over
New Hampshire on projects that will
continue to benefit Granite Staters one
of his last projects was to initiate in
the town of Newcastle the safe path
which affords a safe walking path along
Route 1B all through Newcastle for
children going to School Walkers Runners
families with strollers the path is
nearing completion
Newcastle is a small tightly knit
Community where word travels quickly
so when David decided not to run again
word got back to me that my name was
being bandied about as someone to run
for his seat
I'd never considered the eye before the
idea before and my first reaction is
I knew there was going to be a meeting
to discuss the possibility of my running
and I figured I had better go to protect
myself from absentee volunteerism
you know when you leave to use the
restroom and you come back and now your
chair no
yet after the meeting and hearing people
talk I could reconsider it and here I am
David took on the role of Mentor teacher
Guardian Angel debate partner so so many
roles I could not list he told me that
he would go campaigning with me door to
door in Newcastle and in Rye we walked
and we cycled and we drove I was the
only one who fell off the bike
and I wish I knew how many miles that we
traveled every time before we went out I
told him you don't have to go with me I
can do this by myself and there are tons
of other people who are willing to go
with me
he told me that he wasn't exactly doing
this for me even though he was but he
went on to add that he was doing this so
that when my tenure was over it would be
my turn to go door to door with the
person who followed me just as he was
doing with me now I did not know that
was going to be part of the job but I
can see that's exactly what I will be
doing it's like thanks a lot David for
that
but this defines an important
characteristic
which made David so special
did not think a lot about the president
he was thinking always of the long long
game
he was never thinking of himself he was
thinking of others he was the farmer who
planted the trees that he would never
taste but that would be enjoyed and
valued by every subsequent generation
there are many of these trees in
Newcastle many more across the state of
New Hampshire
this is his legacy and this creates and
ensures his immortality thank you David
you are loved and you sure will be
missed
please rise for a moment of silence in
also attend to send
what reason number arrives Mr Speaker I
move the memorial marks be placed in the
also attend to Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
has the concurrence of the house house
bill 252 exempting certain agricultural
operations from certain Municipal noise
ordinances
representative Aaron moves we concurrent
agritourism from the municipal noise
ordinance exemption that was in this
bill
and our committee concurs and we hope
that you will agree with us and vote to
concur with this Bill thank you
the motion is to occur with to send a
message on House Bill 252. are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
um
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs that the house and the
passage of the following title bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 72
relative to the tenure of public
librarians
is in a winter cotton was we concur with
the Senate message and is recognized to
speak
thank you Mr Speaker we sent this bill
over to the Senate it came back to us
with two words added it added to it
basically allowing the Librarians may be
allowed to stay on until a another one
was
found when there's a vacancy so yes we
do concur on that the motion before us
is to concur with the senator message on
House Bill 72 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
I suppose nay you guys have it in the
motion passes
for the Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs that the house and the
passage of the Fong and title bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill 111 establishing
a committee to study electrical vehicle
representative Walsh moves we concurrent
is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker the original Bill
had three Representatives on this
valuable committee and three senators
the Senate Amendment changes it to one
Senator one three five eight it really
doesn't matter they rarely show up
the motion before assist occur on Senate
on House Bill 111 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
the eyes eyes have it and the emotion
the motion is adopted
for a recognize the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs the house and the passage of the
phone and title bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 137 relative to boating
safety equipment rules and vessel
numbering rules and establishing a
committee to study boat registration
fees
Senate Walter moves that we Concur and
is recognized to speak thank you Mr
Speaker uh the Senate Amendment simply
adds one organization to this committee
the New Hampshire Camp Directors
Association
we ask that you concur
motion before us has occurred on House
Bill 137 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed name the eyes have it and
do you recognize the clerk for further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
occurs that the house and the passage of
the Fall entitled bill with Amendment
the passage which amendment the Senate
has concurrence of the house house bill
268 relative to the Furnishing of
special number plates to The Liquor
Commission division of enforcement and
Licensing and official cover plates for
and Walt moves we concurrent is
recognized to speak thank you Mr Speaker
Senate Amendment simply adds the Senate
clerk to this list we ask that you
concur
the motion before us is the curve on
House Bill 268 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
there's a posenay the eyes have it in
from the committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety Senate Bill 58 removed
by Representatives whole Leon Heinz Tom
Manion Reed Granger Gerhard post
porrigan and Burnham
from the committee on resources
Recreation and development Senate Bill
60 removed by Representatives Heinz Tom
Manion Reed Granger hole Phillips
wheeler Diane Kelly McCarter and Cushman
from the committee on resources
Recreation and development Senate Bill
160 removed by representative Heinz Reed
Horrigan Granger Santa nastasso Tom
minion Burnham Gerhard pole and Phillips
from the committee on science technology
and energy Senate Bill 54 removed by
Representatives corpsman Vose Kaplan
naughter Doug Thomas Wendy Thomas
are there any other bills removed from
the consent calendar
it was an Auburn representative Osborne
moves at the consent calendar with the
relevant amendments is printed in
today's health record be adopted are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye those opposed nay the eyes
have it in the consent calendar is
adopted I also now attend to the regular
calendar
will everybody make sure you turn on
majority of the committee on Judiciary
to which was referred Senate bill 128fn
act relative to payment for legal
services for the persons voluntarily
admitted for mental health services
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senate Bob Lynn for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
from Senator Timmy Horrigan from the
minority of the committee amendment is
1676h printed in house record 24 pages
28.
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I rise today in opposition to
Amendment 1676 to SB 128. almost every
day our constituents ask us to do more
to address the lack of mental health
services available available to them
while we can and should do more we
should most certainly refrain from
making things worse something this
amendment would do especially for our
most vulnerable citizens experiencing
mental health crises
the underlying bill that this amendment
impacts would make three changes related
to the appointment of counsel and
involuntary emergency admission and
commitment proceedings
at issue here with this amendment is one
particular change sb-128's codification
of the state's long-standing practice of
not requiring individuals who experience
a mental health crisis to pay legal fees
to defend petitions for involuntary
emergency admission to the state's
mental health system it is this part of
the bill that the amendment seeks to
change
it's important to understand how these
emergency admissions proceedings unfold
to appreciate the importance of not
disturbing the bipartisan bill that came
over to us from the other body
generally involuntary commitment starts
when someone files an involuntary
emergency admission or an iea petition
stating that a person is a mental
illness causing them to be a danger to
themselves or others the person's
transported to a hospital usually by a
police cruiser and examined by a doctor
the doctor believes the person should be
held on an iea the person generally
remains in the hospital's emergency
department awaiting a remote hearing
before a judge who will determine
whether there is probable cause to
continue to hold the individual
these hearings must occur within three
days of the transport to the hospital
and a person could be held up to 10
working days under certain circumstances
if the court ultimately finds a probable
cause the person may be required to
remain in emergency departments for an
extended period of time with little to
no psychiatric treatment until a bed is
available at New Hampshire hospital or
another appropriate facility
during this process New Hampshire law
rightfully requires that the person
facing institutionalization must have
legal representation typically one of
the small panel attorneys contracted
with the state is appointed to represent
the individual
this amendment would require non-indage
Indigent individuals to pay for their
court appointed attorneys a cost which
currently averages a hundred dollars per
iea case and may not exceed 600 per
involuntary commitment cases
if the court cannot determine indigency
which will likely be which will be
likely in most cases the office of Cost
Containment makes the determination and
could pursue collection
at first blush this amendment might seem
fair it says if someone is Indigent and
cannot pay for legal representation they
should not pay and the alternative if
they are not Indigent they should pay
legal representation costs the amendment
resolves any free rider problem to the
extent it exists it would seem
but the Amendments of study and Paradox
while it may appear to make things fair
and serve the taxpayer interests it does
just the opposite
to begin with it is fundamentally unfair
to force someone in a mental health
crisis
for required legal represent
representation in a proceeding intended
to deprive them of their Liberty and
brought against them only because they
are in crisis they would be forced to
pay for that
quite apart from the means testing
contemplated by this amendment consider
this imbalancing fairness even if
someone has the ability to pay is it
fair we require them to pay for state
required legal representation in a
required hearing they didn't ask for and
one that could result in the state
taking away their Liberty and focusing
them forcing them into treatment
worse yet and however improbable what if
a judge determines that no probable
cause to commit exists in that case
should we require anyone even those with
or without means to pay for required
legal representation this amendment
requires that result
moreover and we heard testimonies this
effect pursuing collection of a payment
only exacerbates someone's Mental Health
crisis thus effectively contributing to
the very conditions that led to the
involuntary proceeding
and importantly it's unfair to remember
this that the taxpayer this is unfair to
the taxpayer because the real costs
associated with determining and pursuing
someone who might be able to pay exceeds
the amount the state would ever recover
in reality the overwhelming majority of
individuals facing commitment are
Indigent thus qualifying the state for
state subsidy subsidization
this makes sense people with means have
access to prevent the occurrence of an
extreme Mental Health crisis in the
first place and chances are less likely
that they're going to find themselves in
a situation where a court determines
whether they should be involuntarily
admitted in other words the pool of
people who might not qualify for State
subsidized legal representation is small
is it even exists
so this amendment effectively focuses on
seeking repayment from a tiny fraction
if that of non-indigent individuals to
be pursued for collection
the costs associated with this effort
investigating individuals Financial
circumstances filing to seek a court
order for repayment are quite high but
the benefits are quite low as we heard
from one witness the office of cost
containment's efforts our collection at
collection are typically quote less than
successful and even investigating
whether someone's not Indigent carries
significant transaction and opportunity
opportunity costs
some the amendment creates costs two
Hydro the taxpayer and too high in cost
of disregarding principles of
fundamental fairness and I urge my
colleagues to reject this Amanda thank
you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I rise in support of
amendment 2023 1676 to SB 128.
SB 128 as it came to us from the other
body does two things
first it transfers responsibility for
making payments for legal counsel
provided to Indigent persons sought to
be involuntarily admitted to the state's
mental health system from the Department
of Health and Human Services where such
responsibility currently lies to the
judicial Council which is responsible
for the payment of legal counsel for
other types of cases such as criminal
Juvenile and abuse and neglect cases
this part of the bill makes perfect
sense and nothing in the proposed
amendment changes this aspect of the
bill
however the other thing that the bill
does is to eliminate the requirement
that persons who can afford to pay for
legal counsel be required to do so the
requirement that persons who can afford
to do so pay for legal counsel in
involuntarily admission admission
proceedings has been a part of our law
since RSA chapter 135c was first enacted
in 1986 and I respectfully submit there
has been no showing made of any reason
to change that requirement yet the way
SB 128 is currently worded if a very
wealthy person and yes it is not only
poor people who can suffer from mental
from mental illness were petitioned to
be involuntarily admitted such person
would have the right to a
court-appointed attorney and the state
would have no ability to recover payment
of the costs of providing such services
from the person in question
there is simply no valid reason for
placing this cost person burden on the
taxpayers when the person in question
has the ability to repay the amendment
before you changes this part of the bill
so as to uh so as to require repayment
of the costs from and I have to
emphasize this from persons who are able
to do so
let me now address the arguments
advanced in opposition to this amendment
first it is claimed that per that
person's facing involuntary emergency
admission are often in a highly volatile
emotional state and that requiring them
to pay for their Council will only
increase uh their uh their emotional
distress
persons petition for involuntarily
admission often are upset and emotional
however it is the fact of this happening
in the first place that is likely the
greatest cause of their upset wait
against the emotional reaction of being
hauled off to a receiving facility
usually a hospital and brought before a
judge for a hearing having to pay for an
attorney likely pales in comparison it
is also important to note that in many
of these cases the person is
involuntarily held at a hospital as I
said and if the person doesn't have
Medicaid and and can afford to repay for
the time spent at the hospital the
person is responsible for those costs
which again are likely to be much
greater than the cost of an attorney
second it is asserted that persons who
are candidates for involuntary emergency
admission will not be able to complete
the financial affidavit necessary to
determine if they qualify for appointed
counsel especially because of the short
three-day time period in which the court
must hold a hearing in such cases this
is a very legitimate concern but based
on conversations I had with judge Keene
of the circuit court and with
commissioner arlinghaus of the
Department of administrative Services
the amendment is specifically drafted to
deal with this situation it says that if
the court is unable to determine whether
a person qualifies for appointed counsel
because of the person's emotional state
the court must appoint counsel anyway
and then the court is directed to refer
the matter to the office of Cost
Containment in the department of
administrative services this is the
office that has been in existence for a
long time and whose Duty it is to
collect repayment of the cost of
attorneys provided by the state to
persons in various types of cases not
just involuntary admission under the
amendment The Cost Containment office
looks into the matter after the fact
that is after the hearing is over and
the person presumably has had a chance
to calm down the office of Cost
Containment decides whether the person
was Indigent and whether the person has
the ability to repay it then provides a
report and recommendation to the court
which makes the final decision on
whether the person has the ability to
repay
please note that in many of this these
situations it may be obvious from the
facts presented at the hearing that the
person is Indigent and can't afford to
pay for example if the police are a
family member show that the person has
been homeless for several months and has
been begging for food that very likely
is sufficient for the court to make a
finding that the person is Indigent and
does not have the ability to repay
without ever making other without even
needing to make a referral to the office
of Cost Containment if a referral is
made and Cost Containment determines
that the person does have the ability to
repay it will so inform the court and
I'm sorry it does not have the ability
to repay
Cost Containment again can so inform the
court and the court can waive the right
of repayment
Cost Containment
may also determine I may also recommend
where it is determined that it will cost
the state more to attempt to collect
than it is likely to require to recover
that no effort at recovery should be
made the amendment is designed to give
the courts and the office of Cost
Containment maximum flexibility to
ensure that repayment is ordered only
where the person actually has the
ability to do so
third it is argued that persons sought
to be involuntarily admitted shouldn't
have to pay for their lawyers because
they didn't ask to have such proceedings
brought against them
but the same could be said about any
person who is named as a defendant in
any civil or criminal proceeding brought
against them by the state or even by a
private party yet except in in very
limited circumstances all such persons
are responsible for paying for their own
Legal Services that's what's known as
the American rule uh in in the legal
system you pay for your you pay for your
own attorney
two other quick points the right to
counsel under chapter 135 applies not
only to emergency involuntary admissions
but also to non-emergency involuntary
admissions which involve admissions for
longer than 10 days and where Court
proceedings can be longer more
complicated and more costly to the state
than the 100 fee typically pay to an
attorney for the Emergency hearings the
fiscal note on this bill estimates that
the total expenditure for year for
Council Services is approximately 1.5
million dollars for these types of cases
this is only the amount for the
attorney's fees and does not include the
costs for related services such as
investigators or expert Witnesses which
sometimes can be far more than the cost
for attorneys
although the state will not be able to
recover all of these funds I submit that
fiscal Prudence to the taxpayers demands
that the state state make reasonable
efforts to recover as much as is
possible from persons again who persons
who are in a position to repay I
therefore urge you to support the
bipartisan uh committee amendment to
this uh to this Bill thank you Mr
Speaker and I would ask for a division
vote
remember yield the questions yes
thank you representative for taking my
question
that was a lot of words
[Music]
um
but
out of it I I think most of us want to
know if someone can repay they would
have to repay how much how much are we
talking about what isn't it capped
what's the amount these people would
have to repay if you can
yes under the under the law as it now
stands and this bill would not change
this aspect of it the amount of the fees
for attorneys are set by the court and
as representative of the as the prior
speaker mentioned for involuntary
emergency admission that's the that's
the admission for the 10-day period the
fee right now is a hundred dollars for
the longer the the longer ones which
um you know which can be for much more
than the fee right now is six hundred
dollars for the attorneys but again bear
in mind that does not include the uh the
other services which sometimes can be
much more than the amount of the
thank you and I do ask for a division
vote if I could Mr Speaker a division
has been requested members will take
foreign
the motion before us
chair recognizes representative Eaton
Mr Speaker
if I know that Senate Bill 128 was asked
for by the judicial branch for the sole
purpose of transferring the cost of
legal counsel from the Department of
Human Services to the judicial Council
if I know that people in involuntary
commitment
do not have
the wherewithal to choose about legal
counsel of their own choosing or whether
to receive appointed counsel
if I further know Mr Speaker that with a
cost is 100 to 600 dollars per
individual
undoubtedly the cost of recovery will
Mr Speaker if I know that
recovery cost agents
are likely to impair the ability for
someone who has gone through an
involuntary commitment
to recover in a speedy and successful
fashion
what I now vote no on the pending
Amendment and go back to the original
bill as requested by the judicial branch
chair recognize representative Lynn for
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this amendment keeps in place
the long-standing requirement that a
person who receives legal counsel and
related services at the expense of the
state in involuntary admissions
proceedings must pay the state for such
expenses if he or she has the ability to
do so and if I know that the amendment
is worded in such a way as to give the
office of administrative Services which
has expertise in this collection area
not only in these kind of cases but in
all other kinds of cases and is not in
any way a you know heavy-handed
collector and exercise and can exercise
its discretion to wave collection where
it either feels that the person doesn't
have the ability to or that it would
cost more than would I would I keep this
aspect of the law The Way It Is by
pressing the green button to approve
this amendment thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is on the amendment
1676h this is a division vote you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposer press the red button voting
foreign
had an opportunity to vote house will
182 voting a 201 voting May the
amendment fails
now we're on to
and representative Marjorie Smith weighs
off
a roll call has been requested or
request a roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the motion of
ought to pass
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair reckon is representative for a
if I know that our constitution requires
that we provide counsel if there is a
need and if I know that that is how we
currently do it
and if I know that this bill now seeks
to give counsel when there is not a need
then I would then press the red vote so
sure I recognize representative Eaton
Mr Speaker if I know by virtue of the
statement involuntary commitment
council is required
and if I know the bill on a bipartisan
basis
simply moved to change who pays the bill
not whether it gets paid who pays it
and Mr Speaker if I know that people in
crisis
are not
simply upset
they are in crisis
in need legal counsel what I now vote
Yes on the bipartisan vote for SB 128.
the motion before us is ought to pass in
Senate bill 128. it's a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposer press the red
button the voting stations are open for
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
207 voting a 177 voting a motion about a
Committee on Public Works and highways
to which I was referred Senate Bill 258
act relative the disposal of highway or
turnpike-funded real estate having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate instead of
David Mills for the committee are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
the eyes have it in the committee report
majority of the committee on resource
Recreation development to which was
referred Senate Bill 164 or FN local
and act relative to consideration of the
biodiversity in the land and Community
Heritage investment program having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexped into legislation of Andy
renzullo from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with majority report the
recommendation to build a lot of pass
Senator Jessica well montane for the
minority of the committee
which I recognizes representative Veil
girl I make a motion to table this bill
motion the motion before us is the table
House Bill 164. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
May
the eyes the eyes have it and the
majority committee on ways and means the
which was referred Senate Bill 120 FN
and act relative to charitable gaming
license for applications wages stakes
and bonds considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
password Amendment Senator Walter
spilsbury from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexped into legislate representative
Richard answer minority of the committee
the amendment is 1577h printed in house
record 24 page 28. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
I suppose May the eyes have it the
amendment is a doctor the chair
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today in opposition to SB 120 FN
because those of us on the Ways and
Means Committee who recommended the itl
agreed that increasing the maximum
single wager from 10 to 50 dollars goes
too far
however we do support an interim step of
moving to 25 dollars before the fifty
dollar limit is voted into law
or limit is a responsible move that
would increase revenue for chosen
non-profits and mitigate potential
losses to players
going to fifty dollars is a five-fold
increase
over current law
and the legislature does have the power
to go to fifty dollars once we see how
the market responds
SB 51 is another reason to wait on this
vote it creates a study commission that
will look at our New Hampshire
non-profit gaming structure
including the revenue from historic
horse racing changes to the selection
and allocation of funds to non-profits
and the effects of wagering on our New
Hampshire citizens
we'll have those results by November of
2024.
so it's prudent to wait for the
committee's findings before making this
bold move today
if you believe that gambling becomes an
addiction when people lose money they
cannot afford
and seek to save themselves by gambling
more
let's give the 25 limit a try before
moving to 50 and consider the findings
proposed by the study Commission
I believe we'll make a more informed
decision about the risks of problem
gambling and the amount of money raised
for the chosen New Hampshire nonprofits
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker colleagues I rise in support
of SB 120 which makes a host of changes
to current law governing charitable
gaming
essentially for the purpose of reducing
bureaucratic hurdles
and raising various caps that have been
placed more or less since 2006.
the only point of difference between the
minority and the majority is the one
question just addressed
whether to raise the current cap
from ten dollars to fifty dollars
the perception
seems to be that the amount we raise the
cap to is going to make a difference in
where the general were typical or
average wager is placed
we don't believe that's true
currently with a ten dollar cap
the typical
wager is one dollar or two dollars
that's where most participants play
so the point of the cap
is not to elevate the practices of the
typical Gainer
point of the cap
is to allow gaming operators to appeal
to and draw in
a narrow niche of high-stakes Gamers
many of whom are coming across the
border to where most of these operations
are played
we don't believe there's a harm
the bill is a very good bill across the
board and this is not a sufficient
reason to vote against it please support
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of autopass has amended
okay the vision was just called for
this will be a division vote members
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 120 this is a
division vote care recognizes
representative Bolton for a
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that as executive director of
a New Hampshire nonprofit
that I find charitable gambling very
helpful in supporting many Charities
throughout the state and if I know that
previous house votes have supported
increasing the single wager from 10 to
25 dollars
but if I also know that an increase to
fifty dollars goes too far and may
contribute to probable gambling would I
now press the red button and oppose
passage of SB 120.
thank you Mr Speaker nice representative
Doucette for parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this
body has supported charitable gaming for
the last I believe it's 17 years but I
also know that the house approved a bill
that did have the 25 Max bet
in it and that went to the Wayside on
the other side of the wall and if I know
that the Charities count on these
dollars and we cannot let the perfect be
the replacement for the good would I
vote green on the octopus
the motion before is the majority can we
report Nevada pass has amended on Senate
bill 120. this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button every opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
202 voting a 182 voting a committee
foreign
okay
the next bill that we're going to be
taking up is Senate bill 272.
I realize this is a highly controversial
and emotional issue
so I'm going to be very strict when
people give their testimony
you will not in any way infringe or
consider somebody else's motives or
impinge somebody else's motives and the
Chamber will remain respectful to the
speakers no booing yelling hollering and
committee on education to which those
referred Senate Bill 272 FN establishing
a parental Bill of Rights in education
the first amendment is
the Builds on second reading open to
I move indefinite postponement of Senate
I'm being informed that to consideration
of the Amendments is a higher priority
so we're on to the First Amendment
which is floor Amendment one eight one
eight
thank you Mr Speaker
Amendment one eight
one eight is uh 272. this amendment
would change the definition of school
that's within this bill currently the
definition in the bill states that a
school is without limitation any school
board
School District school administrative
District or Public Charter School the
amendment changes that definition to
read those
organizations I just mentioned and
any entity that directly or indirectly
so now we've opened this thing up and
we've gone a lot farther than the law
will actually permit us to go
up in my neck of the woods
a number of our students
attend elementary school in Vermont
Samuel Mori school down in Orford is in
Fairly Vermont and part of the
interstate government District what we
have up there between Fairlee Vermont
and Orford New Hampshire
so now what we're doing we're passing
legislation here
that's going to authorize
or try to authorize what's happening to
New Hampshire students in another state
governed by state laws of that state and
also that intergovernmental school
district is governed by articles of
agreement
and policies
and School Board decisions approved by
the Congress of the United States of
America
so we're going to override that as well
not a bad idea but
um
we shouldn't be doing it also
there are a number all up and down that
Connecticut River we have our students
going to schools and entities which
receive funds
from the state of New Hampshire our
Career Technical Education Centers we
have five receiving centers in Vermont
what we're again doing is passing
legislation which is going to tell how
the state over there is going to do
their business but there's another area
we have a number of students in the
state that receive education and support
from residential placement and medical
institutions approximately 600 students
and those students are in those
residential centers 24 7. there's
students which come as a result of what
we used to call catastrophic Aid not
special education Aid they all have IEPs
which require this 24 7 attention and
support
so now we're going to write in
legislation telling how these
residential centers because there are
other entities which receive our funding
how to do business I don't think it will
work seeing that there's different
situations where students are living and
boarding in those particular locations
or housed in a hospital
so in conclusion this amendment never
came before the house education
committee this error would have been
caught
but no it's a floor Amendment and we did
not have a proper hearing on it it is
simply not ready for legislation thank
the motion before us is floor Amendment
one eight one eight Senate Sweeney has
requested roll calls that's officially
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote on the amendment
[Music]
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment one eight one eight this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative magliore for a
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know parents rights
should follow a student regardless of
the school they attend
and if I know the non-public schools
should be subject to the same state
regulations as public schools especially
when accepting funds then would I press
the green button to support this
Geo recognize representative Ladd for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment has not had a public hearing
if I know several questions have been
raised as to how the amendment will
impact tuition program schools located
in both Vermont and Maine
and the interstate school districts
previously approved by the United States
Congress and if I also know this
definition change will have unforeseen
consequences for New Hampshire students
placed in 24 7 residential and medical
facilities where I then press the red
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment one eight one eight this is a
roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
19649 188 voting a committee amendment
is adopted
floor amendment is adopted
the next floor amendment is offered by
representative Merchant one eight one
nine
there is
no debate we will have parliamentary
inquiries
representative Sweeney has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take their
seats
motion before us is floor Amendment one
eight one nine this is going to be a
roll call lower chair recognizes
representative shortlist for
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I rise
today to ask the house to support this
amendment in the wording on this bill if
I know that the wording on this bill is
somewhat ambiguous as if it applies to
certified police officers at a school
resource offices
and if I know that
no child or an adult in a school
district should be afraid to talk to a
law enforcement officer and conversely
that a law enforcement officer shouldn't
be able to interact with a child who
wants to tell them something
and they should not be handcuffed by
this bill
and I also know that if a police officer
who's a resource officer is
investigating a sexual assault case
articulable suspicion to get a warrant
to take
bodily fluids from a 17 year old who is
a prime suspect
that an attorney should not be able to
come back at a later date when that
evidence is conclusive to say it should
not be admitted in court because of this
law I would ask the house to please vote
green on this amendment and not handcuff
the law enforcement offices in New
Hampshire thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Ladd for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know nothing in this bill prohibits
law enforcement from acting in their
official capacity
and if I know this is yet another
attempt to derail the codification of
parent rights
and if I know now is the time to
recognize the parents not schools
not school Personnel are the parents
with all those rights and
responsibilities for their minor
children so parents have that
responsibility would I then press the
red button to dismiss this unnecessary
and untimely Amendment thank you
the motion before us is floor Amendment
one eight one nine this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to say
there are 96 voting yay 189 voting a
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
their merchant offers floor Amendment
one eight three six
there is again
the chair recognize the representative
Ryan
my apologies thank you Mr Speaker I rise
in support of amendment one eight three
six H to Senate bill 272fn this
amendment to accepts to rectify a
destructive portion of this bill that
allows us to sue teachers as a retired
public school teacher I would like to
give you just a snapshot of my day
every 48 minutes a new world of lovely
faces and Wiggly bodilies coming into my
room
in between I need to stand in the
hallway and watch many many many of
those bodies go back and forth
I have bus Duty I have lunch duty and
God forbid I'm sorry heaven forbid I
ever have to Chaperone a middle school
dance ever again
Joey is Dancing with Jimmy Susie is
mugging it up with Sally and 10 minutes
later they're not gay anymore no
disparaging of the children who truly
have those issues but if I have to keep
a record and call every one of those
parents every single time I see Susie
and Sally hugging in the hallway I will
never we will never have another public
school teacher again I strongly
encourage you to go to your public
schools and substitute for your less
than hundred dollars a day and see for
your very own self what this bill will
do to our public schools and our
the motion before us is floor
well
well a member yield to a question
representative Sweeney has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment one eight three six this is
going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that as you walk up
the front stairs of the United States
Supreme Court there are five words
chiseled Above This doorway
and it says Equal justice under the law
in this bill it allow if I know Mr
Speaker that this bill allows for a
plaintiff to re-coupe losses recoup
legal fees and court costs if they
succeed in their
uh
in their in their motion to seek
judgment
would it all but what I also know Mr
Speaker that in this state will we
hold dearly the idea of fairness
that the defendant who has lost sleep
has lost time
and most of all has lost money in
putting up a defense if they prevail
they should receive the same treatment
Equal justice under the law Mr Speaker
would I now push the green button and
level this playing field for all parties
involved thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize representative penternel
another obstacles for parents to seek
retribution for harm caused to their
child creating an impediment for their
duty to protect and defend their
children would I now press the red
button
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1836 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
well Memphis president an opportunity to
198 voting a 187 voting eight four
amendment is adopted
bills on second reading open to Florida
for their Amendment
representative bordes offices floor
-1675
what
is
the amendment before us is short
less than a line long
12 words actually if I don't include the
RSA numbers and the letters at the end
what could go wrong with a short
Amendment
the bill fundamentally changes this law
it takes something that is currently
entitled the parents Bill of Rights and
turns it on its head
our bit
our our
parents our families are entrusted with
the upbringing of their children
that's how Society has been for you for
decades
for centuries for millennia
only recently
I should know
a report a mandatory reporter in fact
put our family through along and arduous
four months
justice system ultimately turned around
and said you're right you're a loving
family you've taken great care of your
children but it wasn't without emotional
every time government gets involved with
a family
there is some level of harm done
the goal
is admirable which is if government's
getting involved
there's less harm at the end
but I'm not sure we're there today with
this amendment
teachers are already mandatory reporters
if they fundamentally believe that
sharing information with the parent will
harm the child they already have an
obligation
that's not changing in this this law
that's not changing in this amendment
that is current law
and while I believe that the system
should be far more efficient it
shouldn't take four months to prove your
innocence
seven years ago eight years ago this
chamber voted on a bill relative to 18
year olds getting
suntan or going to the suntan salons
I don't know who was in the chamber back
then I know I was had a couple of votes
against it but we deemed as a
legislature that we should not allow
those under the age of 18.
to go get a suntan
they can go hang out on their balcony
all day long that's not a problem but
they can't go to a sun tanning salon
I don't know whether that was a good
idea or not there was a child who had
contracted melanoma at the time made a
good argument at the committee level and
eventually on the floor and it passed
but this body decided that something as
mundane as getting a suntan was worth
just what happened
what we're talking about today is
something where children are far more
impacted than a suntan and we believe I
believe I believe that the state
believes
that parents have a right to know that
this is not about as a prior speaker
said mandatory reporting at the
at the middle school dance of so and so
dance with so and so I'm not sure that's
what we're talking about this requires
quite simply that when a parent asks the
school a question that they be given an
if there's anything that we should count
on government for it should be
transparency and openness and honesty if
we can't get those simple things then
I would ask that you would oppose this
amendment because it fundamentally takes
the bill that was the parental Bill of
Rights and turns it on its head and
actually complicates this both legally
and procedurally in such a way that it
could damage families please oppose this
like everybody else in this chamber I I
have received a number of emails
recently
both for and in opposition to Senate
bill 272.
interestingly a number of those emails
that oppose the bill
have a subject line that speaks to the
just this past Sunday we celebrated
Mother's Day
we elevated mothers we put them on a
in another month we'll celebrate the
by deleting sections T through W in this
bill
we're rolling that back
we're just not sure
this amendment says
we're just not sure that parents can be
trusted
last year the chair of the democratic
that if a parental Bill of Rights passes
and parents learn that their child is
gendered on conforming
there's a possibility that they might
I'd like to offer a different
perspective
this comes from a press release issued
by the Log Cabin Republicans just this
past week in support
of Senate Bill 272
it says LGBT youth often experience the
worst that adolescents has to offer
including bullying and feelings of
Despair and isolation
that is when they need their families
the most it is time to bring parents
closer to their child not push them
our public education system depends on
and I'd say nothing says transparency
this amendment strips out language
that says parents have
the right to inquire and be truthfully
and completely informed about certain
things
including names nicknames and pronouns
the gender which they are being
identified as by by School staff
it even strips out a provision that says
parents have a right to know what kind
of extracurricular activities their kids
are involved with
foreign
this amendment flies in the face
of what we believe when we celebrate
Mother's Day and Father's Day
and Elevate mom and dad
to the to the role that we we really
recognize is is vitally important in our
society
Mr Speaker I ask my colleagues to please
thank you Mr Speaker this amendment 1675
H is a basic simple bipartisan
compromise taking out the most
controversial parts of this so-called
parental Bill of Rights
we are focused on parental rights every
single one in here I'm sure can agree we
are four parental rights what sections T
through W do is Target a minority group
of citizens
um and it actually forces teachers and
guidance counselors
and government interference in the
children's privacy
children also should have some privacy
excuse me please don't laugh children
should have some privacy in their class
in their homes in their schools I know I
used to go to my guidance counselor and
discuss situations that I'm not
necessarily wanted my parents to know
well guess what
if this bill goes without with those
lines in it our guidance counselors have
to rat out our students I was going to
give a big long speech but there's a lot
of speakers here today so I urge
everyone to vote Yes on this amendment
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1675
this representative Sweeney has
requested or all calls that's
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
[Music]
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1675
this will be a roll call vote
can't recognize room Center board is for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment strips out the controversial
parts of this bill and makes it a bill
truly about parental rights where I now
vote green thank you
chair recognize representative land for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this amendment deletes
sections T through W of 272 that provide
parents the right to inquire to inquire
of the school or School personnel
to be truthful and responsive to
communicating matters of gender
identification and extracurricular
activity participation to inquire
if I also know hundreds of parents and
Advocates rallied in front of the state
house and testified in this very chamber
in support of 272 just a few weeks ago
and lastly if I believe as a parent
a grandparent
a retired fourth grade teacher
a retired distinguished National
that these rights
are not rights of teachers
they're not rights of the school they're
the rights of parents caring loving
parents wanting to know truthfully what
is going on inside the schoolhouse
I ask you to vote down this Bill thank
you very much
or this this amendment
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1675 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
201 voting a 184 voting a
for a reason to memorize
Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side of the last amendment I
would like to move reconsideration of
the last amendment I would like to urge
the body to vote no and I would request
oh
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill
1675.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposed or press the red button
[Music]
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
184 voting Aid 201 voting a
goes on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative Heinz office floor
Amendment one eight eight six
thank you Mr Speaker
we all agree parents have constitutional
rights you know who also has
constitutional rights children
the one person's rights cannot be
infringed upon another
when people talk to me about this bill
they correctly pointed out that
constitutional rights generally go
against the government this bill the
underlying bill is telling the
government schools what to do as such it
is infringing upon various
constitutional rights of everyone
includes what my Amendment does to say
that students have the right to privacy
freedom of religion freedom of
Association freedom of speech and due
process
decades ago the U.S Supreme Court
addressed an issue dealing with first
amendment in schools they said students
do not shed their first amendment rights
at the schoolhouse gate I'll suggest
that the same is also true for all those
other constitutional rights a few years
ago when New Hampshire passed or amended
our constitution to have the right to
privacy it says an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion in
private or personal information is
essential it didn't say parents rights
in individuals rights I would suggest
that students do have these rights and
we need to protect it and that's what
this amendment does and I ask you to
motion before us is the floor Amendment
1886.
Sam Sweeney has requested a roll call us
that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
motion before us the floor Amendment
1886 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Heinz for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the
Constitution protects everyone would I
then support this bill or Amendment vote
yes thank you
chair recognize representative Lynn
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment which is a basically a poison
pill Amendment will fundamentally
undercut the purpose of this bill as it
came to us from the Senate and if I know
that the various rights of children that
the amendment references could easily be
construed by a court to be intended to
apply against the parents if they were
included in this bill whereas they would
never otherwise be construed in that way
than would I reject this amendment by
pressing the red button thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us is floor Amendment
one eight eight six this is a roll call
vote you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button boarding stations are
yesterday
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
19848 187 voting a the amendment is
adopted
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment Senate of Hines office floor
Amendment 1907.
representative Heinz
thank you Mr Speaker this amendment's
more narrow than my last one I don't
know if it was the intent of the bill or
not or an oversight but my position is
the underlying bill would essentially
prohibit or not prohibit if a student
tells their school counselor something
then that counselor is required or
psychologist required to tell that
information of the parent
under the underlying bill this changes
that to make an exception so that
students have a right to privacy if it's
reasonably objective when they tell
information to their counselor school
psychologists school nurse or other
certified health provider when people
talk about Secrets I have a different
word for that it's called privacy if
kids are going to a psychologist or a
counselor and they're telling them very
intimate things knowing that that's
going to be related to their parent when
they ask I suggest they're less likely
to tell the psychologists that and
they're less likely to get the help that
they need
if parents want to ask a question of
their child you should be asking the
child not the school
different things that people could tell
a counselor include their sexual
identity gender identity it could be
whether they are sexually assaulted
could be information regarding STD
testing
different information regarding birth
control a lot of intimate things that
someone could be telling a counselor I
suggest that should say between them and
the counselor I would expect a counselor
might talk the child through this and
ultimately say hey it would be best to
get your parent involved with this but
at the end of the day it should be the
student being the one to make that
decision
um in a case Sterling the borough of
Minersville there was a case where a
police officer found an 18 year old and
a 17 year old engaged in say same-sexual
sex relationship and they threatened to
tell that person's parent about that
relationship that person committed
suicide this parent then it sued and the
Supreme Court or not Supreme Court the
Third District allowed the lawsuit to go
forward saying matters of personal
intimacy are protected from threats of
Disclosure by the right to privacy so
there's a limiting bill and I would
suggest it's needed so that students can
get the mental health help that they
motion before us is the four Amendment
1907.
representative Sweeney has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1907.
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Heinz for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know our laws
already product confidentiality with
school psychologists would I then extend
that protection and enable or keep it
for children in Vogue green thank you
[Music]
chair recognized from senator cordelli
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this amendment provides
counselors with secrecy Provisions that
are contrary contrary to their ethical
standards which required a balanced
approach and discussion with parents and
if I know that this amendment
provides for unknown student
confidentiality rights
would I now vote for parents by pressing
the red button
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1907 it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
you can't push it now it's closed Gotta
well members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
198 voting 180 sub voting a floor
the question is now when autopath has
amended for what reason does a member
rise
thank you Mr Speaker move indefinite
postponement of Senate bill 272.
motion is in order
for what reason does it member rise Mr
Speaker I moved to lay 272 on the table
that is a higher priority motion so the
motion before us will lay
a division has been requested
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on Senate bill 272. this is a
gear recognize the representative
Sweeney for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the Amendments already adopted
today on Senate Bill 272 fundamentally
changed the bill and further Mr Speaker
if I know that considering that
fundamental change of the bill would
rise into question what impact any other
motion might have for instance
indefinite postponement and if I know
further that we should not be cutting
our legs off in order to have this
continued discussion and debate that we
we had thoroughly today would I now vote
the green button to table Senate Bill
272 thank you
yeah I recognize your representative
if I know that over 500 bills have been
introduced in State legislatures this
year specifically targeting vulnerable
lgbtq plus people
and if I know that we need to debate and
dispense with this bill today and if I
want the opportunity to act on this bill
as soon as possible to give relief to
New Hampshire parents students and
teachers would I now press the red
[Music]
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on Senate bill 272. it's a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
okay
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
in 86 voting a 199 voting May the motion
to table fails
for
questions we're back to the motion now
the assigned motive that there was
legislation specifically targeting a
I I did not see that that went over
so I'm I'm not going to accept that the
motion before us now
is back to the motion of indefinite
postponement
roll call has been requested is
efficiently second it is sufficiently
motion the motion before house will be
in order
the motion before us is the emotion of
investment indefinite postponement on
Senate Bill 272 chair recognizes
representative Simpson for a
thank you Mr
if I know that adolescent development
involves identity exploration and
finally if I know that having trust
between students and teachers means that
students have better mental health
outcomes and lower suicide rates would I
now press the green button to
indefinitely postpone SB 272
thank you
chair recognize representative Osborne
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
adoption of this motion will not only
ensure that we do not act today but will
also ensure that we do not even discuss
this topic in this body for the
remainder of the biennium
and if I know
that this will send a message to parents
that they must continue until the next
election when they can replace their
representatives that they must
continue to accept that school is a
mysterious and secretive Black Box where
they deposit their children who knows
what happens inside that box and who
knows what comes out the other side
the
[Music]
if I further know Mr Speaker that we
will be sending a message to parents
that they have no choice but to Avail
themselves of the already wildly
successful education Freedom account
program which thankfully we have
expanded this year to service even more
children than ever before would I now
the motion before us
is indefinite postponement on Senate
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your impulse you'll press the red button
all members president had an opportunity
to vote I also attend the state of the
vote
195 voting a 190 voting a indefinite
house will be in
share recognize representative dutse for
uh Hillsborough County delegation will
be meeting having a very short meeting
during the lunch hour in section five if
everybody from Hillsboro can join us
we'll make it as short as possible thank
you
culture which was for in Senate Bill 267
FN
an act requiring the commissioner of
Department of Environmental Services the
to consider accommodative impacts
analysis and rules statutes have been
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
bill on a printed in house record 24
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
Professor post nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted this is going
to be a division vote
Foundation
the motion before us is ought to pass
that amended on Senate bill 267. this is
going to be a division vote chair
recognizer representative Harrington for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know allowing cumulative impact analysis
to be put into statute as a basis for
deciding which projects in the state go
forward and which don't that'll
basically put everything to a standstill
this and if I know Mr Speaker allowing
this type of analysis has no end to it
you can cumulative impact means you can
take this element and that element and
analyze that and then someone can say
what about another element and so forth
and so on if I know organizations like
the conservation law Foundation have
been pushing this so they can have
endless lawsuits to prevent any
expansion of anything in New Hampshire
and I know Des has not requested this
bill would I then push the red button
and retain some sanity and out citing
process in New Hampshire thank you
do you recognize representative
Mr Speaker
if I knew that the environmental
agriculture committee listened to hours
of testimony and voted 19-0 all had to
pass
if I further knew that we heard
overwhelming evidence and support of
this bill and finally if I knew that
this bill was going to in fact help
protect our water and our environment
would I not pass the green button to
pass HB 267 thank you
the motion before us was ought to pass
as amended on Senate Bill 267 this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you oppose or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
302 voting yay 77 voting a committee
committee on Executive Department's
Administration to which was referred
Senate Bill 195 FN relative the purchase
of Steel products with buy American
certification having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
bill I could pass Senator Jason Grotti
for the committee
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment Senator Grotti offers floor
Amendment 1727 h
P printed in
house record 24 page 29.
chair recognizes representative Carol
McGuire
her existing buy American Steel statute
it was requested by administrative
services and the
Steel Fabricators so everyone's an
agreement the amendment is because a
very sharp-eyed legislator actually read
the bill without being familiar with it
and noticed that between the bottom of
page one and the top of page two a line
had been left out this amendment puts
the line back in and I hope you all
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1727 h
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted motion before
us now is auto pass has amended you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
doll's name the ice
eyes have it and the
enjoy the committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred Senate Bill 32 FN
enact relative to opioid abatement trust
fund having considered the same report
the same with the recommendation of Bill
a lot of pass
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment representative lawyer on
offers floor Amendment one eight three
three h
speaker today I rise in support of this
amendment which combines the minority
Amendment with the language of house
bill 287.
this bill came to our committee without
a solid definition of harm reduction and
despite opening up the critical opioid
trust fund to what could be a blank
check
recognizing that contaminated street
drugs caused Great harm for the consumed
drug consumers in our state and
recognizing that New Hampshire has no
eyes on the street to sample or maybe I
should say assay the contaminants and
street drugs the minority of committee
believed that the most clear and present
danger for harm reduction would to be
ensured to would be to ensure that we
are going to test those street drugs for
contaminants
this has always been a two-pronged
approach we could fund it but unless we
change the laws so that the testing
equipment is no longer considered drug
paraphernalia it wouldn't be possible to
use any funds for that in the state
so what we have done here is to specify
that we would use these funds for drug
testing and then also to add back House
Bill 287 which was passed unanimously
unfortunately our colleagues on the
other side of the wall are looking to
reduce this just to fentanyl test strips
but we have other threats here that are
in our opioids we have tranq that's the
drug that does not respond to Narcan we
don't know how much of it that of it is
in our street drugs in other states they
have surveillance and they have street
level testing and they're able to see
which communities it's moving into so
that people can be appropriately
cautious and perhaps some of those users
will decide to go into treatment and to
avoid those street drugs to avoid that
clear and present threat of death
if you're dead you can't recover and we
should give people the tools in order to
do this
so the amendment in front of you is
intended to focus our limited opioid
abatement dollars on drug testing as
opposed to a broader definition of harm
reduction and to also have the legal
framework in order to do this
I ask for your support so that we can
have fewer drug users that are
unknowingly taking dangerous deadly
contaminants like Fentanyl tranq and
thank you Mr Speaker
um
for every complex social problem there
is a solution that's neat simple and
wrong
That's The Story of My Life anyways
first of all I would like to begin by
thanking representative Leon for
bringing this issue up it's an extremely
important issue it's something that we
really need to think about
the reason why I'm opposing it is
because it's it changes the SB 32 in a
way that I think could be harmful I
don't think I will be harmful
for those of you who don't know me
um I'm a physician I've worked in New
Hampshire for the last 34 years serving
the needs of people with complex
disability particularly pain
I've traveled all over the area the
country and internationally to Advocate
on the rights of people with chronic
pain and as part of that I'm really
proud to be the vice chair of the opioid
debate commission which is actually the
subject of says p32
the words harm reduction which this
amendment would actually strike from SB
332 are very important to me and to
those I represent and I'm honored to be
standing here in support of them and to
oppose the amendment
first of all the primary purpose of SB
32 is actually to align two programs one
is the governor's Commission on Alcohol
and Other Drugs with the opioid
abatement advisory commission both in
terms of function and terminology
the governor's commission was created in
2000 to address what at that time was
already an important existing drug
crisis and we've had a drug crisis for
as long as the 40 years as I've been
here
alcohol has been a huge problem and that
was one of the major reasons that was
created it's function is to advise the
executive department and the legislature
on the delivery of effective
collaborative and coordinated prevention
treatment and Recovery substance use
programs and other services
the action plans that they've created
for this next two years and for the
previous two years stress harm reduction
as a priority
the opioid abatement advisory commission
was created
in 2020 and it manages the opioid
abatement trust fund which comes from
dollars and cents that come from the
lawsuits from various pharmaceutical
agencies and whatever
as part of our function we review Grant
applications and award funding to
deserving community and government
agencies using one or more of 16
different criteria which are in statute
it's important for you to know that
There are rules on how who gets this
money it has to be only for the use of
opioid abatement nothing else
one of the things that's missing from
this statute though is that there's no
mention of harm reduction and that's
what SB 32 seeks to remedy and includes
the word support secondary and tertiary
prevention through harm reduction
programs is a criteria for dispensing
funds
a critical pillar of both programs then
is harm reduction which is a
comprehensive preventative strategy it
is not a single intervention I've been
working with people for complex
disabilities my entire life and the one
thing that we have learned is that
single modality treatment does not work
you can give somebody methadone but
methadone does not alone does not work
you can give somebody buprenorphine
buprenorphine alone does not work you
need to have people working together in
a collegial Cooperative environment
for effective treatment prevention
whatever and that is what harm reduction
actually is
the thing that bothers me a lot is that
this has been acknowledged in eastern
medicine for over 2 000 years we in the
west are slow in catching on to this
I would say that the Insight of
stressing harm reduction is a primary
strategy for managing substance use
disorder in New Hampshire is both
ingenious and necessary
this is consistent with published
opinions from the substance abuse mental
health services
Administration which I will from here on
in refer to as samsa because I don't
feel like saying all those words
and the Rand corporation whose state
harm reduction is a critical
evidence-based element to the Strategic
success of opioid abatement programs as
part of a comprehensive strategy samhsa
outlines Seven Elements to harm
reduction which have been shown to
prevent death
injury disease overdose infectious
disease transmission and misuse
all of those are present in the
governor's statement commission
statement
the problem is if this amend would have
approved
all these critical harm reduction
Services would be moved from
consideration by the opioid abatement
advisory commission except for drug
checking which again is extremely
important but only one of things I would
say that this is functional like asking
me to build a house giving me a toolbox
but only putting a screwdriver in it
while drug checking is important this
amendment would arbitrarily deny many
other very worthy programs access to
funding that they desperately need and
would unnecessarily harm those in need
of comprehensive integrative
interdisciplinary Services by denying
them access to those services
we do have a very large drug problem in
this state which I'm sure everybody in
this room is aware of real people who
could benefit from these funds are
unnecessarily suffering from Pain
addiction mental health disorders they
need this funding now and they deserve a
better comprehensive care plan this
amendment would unnecessarily create a
barrier which I would ask us to not
create and I would also like to add that
we representative Leon is totally right
one of our big concerns was definitions
and we will talk about that with SB 239
we do have a definition of harm
reduction which we will share for you at
that time that I think clarifies a lot
of this for these reasons though I would
ask you to please press the red button
so that this overly restrictive
Amendment may be defeated and More in
need may have access to life-saving
a division has been requested members
the motion before us is to lay on floor
Amendment one eight three three h
on let's say division vote
chair recognize representative laying on
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that 381
million dollars is a large amount of
money but still has a lot of areas where
it needs to serve and if I know that it
is critical to make sure that we
emphasize that we need to have drug
checking available in this state would I
then press the green button to support
this amendment thank you
Joe recognize representative for a
thank you Mr Speaker
I've just been asked a wonderful
question that I've edited a little part
to Mr Speaker if I knew that people with
chronic pain who represent 66 million
people in America
1.25 of people or million people in
Hospice in a hollerative care who
previously got decent pain management
prior to the public policy response to
opioid epidemic who now can't get it
would now be able to access funds if
harm reduction was included in our
definition and if I know
that this amendment or this bill without
Amendment passed our committee with a
vote of 16-3 and if I know many worthy
organizations desperate for funding and
Manpower which provide life-saving harm
reduction services for opioid use
disorder would be denied access to
opioid abatement funds if this amendment
passed and if I know it is critical that
these two commissions share
well-established evidence-based
nationally and internationally accepted
terminology and practices not just to
distribute opioid abatement funds but
also to remain competitive in receiving
grants and awards from other sources
then I would press the red button to
defeat this amendment thank you the
motion before us is the floor Amendment
one eight three three h this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if your opposed or
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
members president an opportunity to vote
152 voting Aid 230 voting a the floor
Amendment fails we're back to ought to
pass the chair recognizes representative
Leon
president of Nagel
waving off
the motion before us has ought to pass
on Senate Bill
32. are you ready for the question all
you guys have it and the committee
report is adopted
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred seven Bill 85 an act
relative to emergency Behavioral Health
Services and behavior Behavioral Health
crisis programs having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Erica Leon
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs which
was referred Senate Bill 85
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Joe Shapiro chair
thank you madam speaker
and good afternoon members
Mr Speaker Madam speaker excuse me I
rise in opposition to the 10 to 9
committee vote of itl for Senate bill
85. this bill passed the other body
unanimously with support across the full
political Spectrum
it would Place Mental Health emergencies
On a par with physical health
emergencies and that's to say when
someone is having a heart attack
currently that person needs to be
treated right now
not after an insurance company has given
its prior authorization
so similarly when someone is having a
mental health crisis that person needs
immediate professional attention
not professional health attention after
an insurance company has allowed it
timing is critical
there are many in the house who believe
that recent events and specifically mass
shootings that we are witnessing and not
because of guns but because of mental
health issues
with the individuals carrying out these
horrible Acts
irrespective of what we may believe
about guns it seems to be true that many
of the shooters had
and have mental health issues
what if when someone is seen to be
having a crisis that treatment is
delayed as a result wouldn't many people
then conclude
myself included that the only answer
left would be to Red Flag such a person
and confiscate the guns
that's what voting itl might lead to
at present there was a committee to
examine how many committees should be
abolished so why add another one which
is referenced in Senate Bill 85
but actually if you read the bill what
happens is a replacement of one
committee with another so therefore
there's a net zero gain in terms of the
number of committees
the newly constituted committee will
look at how other states fund programs
similar to what Senate Bill 85 is
establishing
there are some Frugal States in our
country which have programs similar to
what Senate Bill 85 proposes how they do
it
and how do they achieve their goals with
good economic sense
further how can we address the crisis in
real and Frugal ways that's one issue
that this reconstituted committee
we'll examine
further concern was raised that someone
might fake a Comm a mental crisis simply
to get attention
the bill speaks however and I'll quote
it's in the bill the sudden onset of a
medical or mental health condition or
substance use disorder that manifests
itself
by symptoms of sufficient severity that
a prudent layperson with average
knowledge of health and Medicine could
reasonably expect that the absence of
immediate medical or mental health
attention could be expected to result in
any of the following and I'll stop there
that's unquote because what follows is
already in law and that's in the bill
that hopefully youth have in front of
you
the law is there already for sudden
physical health conditions
the bill recognizes that mental health
conditions are parallel
so we asked
together
for your support
with the unanimous decision from the
other body
and with a
enhanced common sense of the
multitasking it takes to meet the
challenges of both mental and physical
health emergencies
that we vote no on itl
and consider another motion to then be
made
thank you madam speaker
the chair recognizes representative Leon
to speak for the majority of the
committee
thank you madam speaker
I rise in favor of inexpedient to
legislate on Senate bill 85. this bill
has the noble intention of addressing
the emergency room boarding crisis and
mental health problems but in trying to
cover one square foot it covers many
many acres
now I recognize that we have a mental
health crisis and it appears that just
yesterday multiple lives were lost to
the Mental Health crisis very close to
it's a tragedy and every person unable
to access appropriate care and every
life's lost to violence which stems from
a mental illness is a tragedy but we
don't we don't solve this problem by
providing a solution that is so broad as
to use pressure precious resources in an
inefficient manner
if you have one weed in the middle of
your lawn you don't coat the whole lawn
with Roundup if it's a dandelion or an
Autumn Olive you go to the root and get
the whole route out if it's crabgrass
you mow down in that area so that it
doesn't keep spreading if you have a
mental health crisis that's as large as
we have you make sure that you're not
increasing your mandates for insurance
coverage so much that you lose access to
the very limited care providers that we
have today we need to have other
processes in order to be able to
increase the amount of care that we are
able to provide and having a massive
broad reaching increase in Insurance
mandates in order to try to address a
problem is not the right solution we're
going to dilute our offerings and we're
not going to get to where we need to be
simply put this bill has good intentions
but the unintended consequences will set
us back not move us forward therefore I
ask that you support the inexpedient
legislate motion thank you
the motion before the house is the
majority recommendation of itl on Senate
Bill 85. are you ready for the question
division has been requested this will be
a division vote all members will take
foreign
recognizes representative Shapiro for a
[Music]
thank you madam speaker
Madam speaker if I know that the mobile
crisis teams are a key strategy enacted
by this legislature and implemented by
the Community Mental Health Centers
across the state to alleviate the ER
boarding crisis
and if I know that mobile crisis teams
are but one part of a comprehensive
behavioral crisis stabilization system
planned by the Bureau of Mental Health
Services
and if I further know that the funding
to complete and sustain these Services
is uncertain
and Madam speaker if I know that the
limitation on pre-authorizations refers
only to the mobile crisis team
responding to acute psychiatric crises
and if I know that psychiatric crises
acute psychiatric crisis is not the time
to pursue pre-authorizations from an
insurance company
would I then push the red button to
defeat the itl motion so that another
motion can be made to ensure sustainably
funded effective community-based crisis
the chair recognizes representative Leon
thank you madam speaker if I know that
large increases Insurance in Insurance
mandates require careful consideration
and that our resources need to be
appropriately allocated would I then
press the green button thank you
the question is on the majority
committee recommendation of itl on
Senate Bill 85 this will be a division
vote if you are in favor you will press
the green button if you are opposed
you'll press the red button voting
foreign
[Music]
have all members president have the
opportunity to vote the house will
with 159 in the affirmative 223 and the
for what reason doesn't memorize
I I move out to pass representative
Weber moves ought to pass on Senate bill
85. I and a division has been requested
the chair recognizes representative
Stephen person for against parliamentary
thank you madam speaker
Madam speaker if I know we are facing a
serious and growing Mental Health crisis
that needs addressing
and if I know that this bill does not
add a new committee to the hundreds we
already have but rather changes an
existing committee to one that is tasked
with finding financially responsible
Solutions
and finally if I know this bill came to
us with a unanimous bipartisan vote
and if I also know that as the vice
chair of the PTSD commission this is
something
that really deserves the state's
attention would I now press the green
button
the chair recognizes representative
Shapiro for a parliamentary inquiry
representative Shapiro is waving that
off the question is on the ought to pass
motion on Senate Bill 85 this will be a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red vote button voting
have all members president had the
opportunity to vote the house will tend
with 271 in the affirmative 112 of the
negative the ought to pass motion
carries
and it's referred to the committee on
Commerce
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred Senate Bill 127 FN an
act relative to certain programs
administered by the Department of Health
and Human Services have been considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Wayne
McDonald for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee have been
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jim Cole fault for the minority
the the bill is open to Amendment and
you'll find is it floor Amendment
committee Amendment
question is on the amendment is are you
ready for the amendment 1457 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those are paid all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
okay now the question is on the ought to
pass as Amendment on Senate Bill 127.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the ought to pass
the majority of the committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
which was referred Senate Bill 200 an
act relative to optometrists having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Gary
Merchant for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
have been considered the same in being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Yuri
paulozov for the minority of the
committee
the motion before us is amendment
majority Amendment 1568 h
inted in house record 24. are you ready
for the question
all those in favor say aye all those
opposed say nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the bill is open to further Amendment
Amendment minority amendment number 1583
H printed in house record 24 on page 30.
chair recognizes representative
pullos off
thank you madam speaker
support of amendment
1583 age
zandaline bill will prompt optometrist
to administer covet vaccines which is a
medical drug for public health funding
it's free and yet it provides billions
of dollars for manufacturers and
millions in federal transfers for New
Hampshire health organizations and it
gives them Unity to those involved legal
immunity but what about real immunity
since this bill was introduced new
scientific data showed that the ringing
Effectiveness if at all
antibody level drops so fast that it
would require several boosters a year to
this month on my second published that
individuals with covid-19 vaccinations
had a high risk of all forms of retinal
vascular occlusion they want
optometrists to inject something that in
two years causes occlusion in your eyes
and federal agencies since recognized
those connections between these vaccines
and strokes and lowered doses of this
vaccines for certain demographics not
because it's too efficient because it
doesn't stop transmission and doesn't
prevent disease because it's dangerous
if we use optometrist to vaccinate
everyone has certain candidates will die
and it's a bipartisan position of the
health human services and the llfs
committee that side effects of covid-19
vaccines are underreported that's why we
just voted for majority Amendment but
majority Amendment doesn't go far enough
we can't wait two years to protect our
constituents we need to do it now this
medicine disproportionately harms
liberal constituents who on the specific
issue class that the former president
and our government administrations
saying that it is safe and effective
it's everything but safe anything but
safe and effective and for this reason
Madam speaker I use the support of this
amendment press the green button and I
ask for division vote and I'm right
with the
representative Yale for a question
the representative yields you may ask
your question thank you madam speaker
and thank you representative for taking
my question is there an importance to
address this uh some of these new
vaccine technology
even as we see now with the flu vaccine
thank you for these questions uh
opponents of this amendment saying that
mRNA technology is safe and effective
because it was researched for many years
but if it was fully researched why
nobody informed us that it won't stop
the transmission and won't prevent the
disease why nobody told us two years ago
that it will be associated with
myocarditis and slog so so and and why
women were gaslighted who had periods
messed up by these medications so side
effects are not well researched I I saw
this certificate data of 60 plus years
old New Hampshire residents who perished
in Massachusetts Hospital
killed by lipid nanoparticles
phospholipids and it's not the single
case we don't know how often it happens
the same with the American Technology
and new report shows that there's
contaminations with DNA in this vaccines
is it important finally most common case
they're saying that Spike protein itself
that is being produced in the body after
this vaccination can have
cardio toxicity and other effects so we
don't know
science
needs a year or two
to figure out which one of this or some
other Technologies in this new
vaccines causing side effects blindness
and sometimes death so I the only thing
I'm asking is give us a year or two to
properly research this topic thank you
the chair recognizes representative
Koval and I'll mention that a division
vote has been requested so you want to
many members of this chamber may know
that I have a keen interest in the topic
of vaccination I've introduced a number
of bills that have to do with it
that interest is driven by several
principles including patient consent
parental consent
and maximizing Freedom both for
practitioners and for patients
the underlying Bill to which this
amendment applies
expands Freedom it increases the number
of people who are authorized to
administer vaccines in the state of New
Hampshire to include optometrists
that authorization extends only to
administering vaccines to adults not to
children
like my esteemed colleague who just
spoke
I I also believe that the covid-19
vaccines and mRNA vaccines have not been
proven to be safe and effective that's
why I personally have chosen not to get
the covet vaccine
I respect the rights of everyone else in
this room and out there to make up their
own mind about whether or not they want
to get that vaccine
by amending this bill we are
expanding freedom to to offer to to to
allow more people to give vaccinations
but then we are clawing back some of
that authorization by saying well you
can only do certain kinds of
vaccinations
so in the spirit of maximizing freedom
for patients and practitioners I urge my
colleagues to vote no on this amendment
so that we can pass a good clean bill
that expands Freedom thank you madam
speaker
the motion before us is amendment 1583 H
this will be a division vote members
[Music]
the chair recognizes representative
thank you madam speaker if I know that
optometrists will be under enormous
pressure if this bill passes and if I
know that they typically do not listen
to patients Hearts do not take patients
blood pressure and do not have a handle
on the patient's full medical history
and if I know that side effects
associated with covid-19 vaccines are
underreported
and finally if I know that more
peer-reviewed studies were published
regarding
blindness and even deaths caused by
these vaccines
would I now press the green button to
allow for a reasonable delay for these
new under-tested technologies
the chair recognizes representative
thank you madam speaker
if I know this amendment does not
support patient freedom of choice
and if I know an appropriately trained
optometrist a safety administer a
vaccine
and if I know this amendment failed the
committee with a solid bipartisan vote
what I now push the red buttons to the
amendment thank you
motion before us is on Amendment 50
15 83
Eastern vote if you're if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
have all members president had the
opportunity to vote the house will
with 105 votes in the affirmative 275
the negative motion fails the motion
before us now is on the odd to pass as
amended with Amendment 1568 H are you
ready oh uh and the chair recognizes
representative Merchant for a
so the motion before us is ought to pass
as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
[Music]
um
yes we're using those to remember wise
thank you madam speaker I believe a
division
vote was called for before you pull down
the gravel
therefore I think we should do the
division
I did not hear that let me consult with
foreign
the chair is in doubt and I did not hear
it I apologize I did not hear the
request for a division but this will be
a division vote the challenge though now
is I if people have left the room or
come into the room after the vote this
can only be the people who are in the
room at the time of The Voice vote thank
the motion before us has ought to pass
is amended on Senate Bill 200 this will
be a division vote if you are in favor
you press the green button if you'll
oppose you press the red button voting
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
with 239 voting in the affirmative 145
the committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred Senate Bill
239 FN relative to use of harm reduction
services to treat alcohol and other
substance misuse comes to us without
recommendation the chair recognizes
representative Weber to move ought to
pass yes
with Amendment 1754.
the motion before us is ought to pass on
1754. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
[Applause]
Division I will request a division on
that I am unclear on the vote members
who are already in the room
pleased to vote on this this will be a
the question is on Amendment 1754 this
will be a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative spilsbury
have all members president had the
opportunity to vote the state the house
with 249 and affirmative 127 in the
negative the motion carries
the bill is now open to further
Amendment representative Nagel moves
floor Amendment 1861 H and is recognized
I'm a teacher thank you madam chairman
speaker speaker sorry
the running theme of um Senate Bill 239
was aligning the terminologies in the
governor's commission and the opioid
abatement advisory commission with best
practice nationally accepted language
specifically replacing the word
substance abuse with the broader term
substance misuse which would allow us to
increase certain groups with access to
abatement funds including pain-related
issues that we talked about earlier but
more importantly as we're going to talk
about now at emphasizing harm reduction
strategies the problem is that neither
of those two terms was defined in
statute where substance abuse is defined
the term misuse does appear in RSA 12j
which creates the governor's permission
but again it's not defined the term harm
reduction does not appear anywhere but
is prominently appears in the last two
Governors commission action plans
we concluded that these two definitions
both needed warrant a warranted
definition by Statute
what you just voted on actually created
a definition for misuse but it created a
definition for harm reduction that many
of us had a trouble a problem with
so we talked a great deal about how to
fix that initially we used the samsa
definition that basically harm reduction
is an approach that emphasizes engaging
directly with people who use drugs to
prevent overdose and infectious disease
transmission improve physical mental and
social function of those served and
offer low threshold options for
accessing substance use disorder
treatment and other health care
some of us felt that that definition was
too narrow some of us felt that it was
too broad so a couple of us sat down
tried to figure that out and what we did
was we looked at number National
websites also the governor's commission
existing language and that's what we
came up with was what you see now is the
current
Amendment 1861.
um it reconciles these concerns by
reitering samhsa definition of harm
reduction and limiting the scope to
eight harm reduction interventions which
are both listed by samhsa and already
exists in the governor's commission
action plan by adopting this definition
we can increase the potential list of
grantees for the opioid abatement fund
through a broader definition of harm
reduction and Drug misuse use
terminology that is more consistent with
what is considered best practice and
used nationally promote a coordinated
Cooperative interdisciplinary model of
care which is badly needed for substance
use disorder in the state and promote a
comprehensive preventive strategy as a
ways of controlling the adverse effect
of opioids and the other drugs in crisis
now
also that's important it will increase
the access for underfunding sources for
these programs and finally affect more
lives in a positive way in order to
improve access to care for those
affected I would urge you to press the
green button to support this amendment
thank you
the motion before us is amendment 1861 H
uh the division vote has been requested
so this will be a division vote members
question before us is on the motion of
ought to pass on Amendment 1861 H this
will be a division vote the chair
recognizes representative co-fault for
thank you madam speaker
Madam speaker if I know that a majority
of the committee supports the intent of
this bill
but that without a clear definition
of harm reduction
the current version of the bill offers
virtually a blank check to spend money
on anything that advances quote social
and mental well-being
and furthermore if I know that
15 members of the committee voted
against the itl motion because they
really want to support the underlying
intent of this bill would I then press
the green button to pass this amendment
so that we can vote for the bill in good
conscience thank you madam speaker
for us is an ought to pass on 1861 H
this will be a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the
question is on the amendment
on the floor Amendment 1861 H if you are
for the amendment you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
have all members present have the
opportunity to vote the house will
with 359 in the affirmative 18 in the
motion before us now is on the
ought to pass as amended are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye all those opposed say nay
[Applause]
this bill will go to the committee on
finance
s
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which
to which was referred Senate Bill 263 FM
extending the New Hampshire granted
Advantage Health Care Program
in re-establishing the commission to
evaluate the effectiveness the future of
New Hampshire granted Advantage Health
Care program that comes to us without
recommendation
of Leon moves ought to pass and offers
chair recognizes representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues
I stand before you to speak in
opposition to the amendment
this amendment that will reduce the
reauthorization of granted advantage to
a six-year term
Medicaid expansion has provided ready
access to medical care for low-income
granted Staters for the past nine years
and SB 263 as it arrived from the other
body seeks to permanently reauthorize it
when it expires at the end of this year
this was the clear and empath and
emphatic recommendation of the
commission created to evaluate the
effectiveness of granted advantage
granted Advantage provides tens of
thousands of New Hampshire residents
with primary care preventive services
and Specialty Care when necessary
it has resulted in significant reduction
in uninsured residents and in
uncompensated care costs
while also reducing insurance rates on
the individual Market
additionally granted advantages
contributed to a healthier and more
resilient Workforce
the availability of coverage through
granted Advantage has also proven to be
an essential Lifeline for those
suffering with substance misuse
disorders and mental illness
originating in the Senate SB 263
reauthorizing granted Advantage without
a sunset arrived at the house with a
unanimous bipartisan ought to pass vote
from that body
24 to nothing
it was it has broad and enthusiastic
support from the business Community from
medical providers large and small from
advocates for public health and from
those who provide treatment for
substance use disorders and mental
illness
reducing the term of granted advantage
to six years will unnecessarily
complicate Medicaid expansion going
forward
it is less than optimal for the
procurement of Managed Care contracts
provider organizations faced with an
uncertain future will be unable to plan
strategically
and most important fellow Granite
Staters will be unable to count on
continued Medical Care
granted advantages to successful program
with proven results for close to a
decade
should Federal funding decrease below
the current 90 percent match
the program will automatically be
discontinued
permanent reauthorization of granted
Advantage will provide security for
low-income residents and for health care
providers generally
it will enhance Public Health while
ensuring the viability of Health Care's
of of a Health Care System under
considerable stress
there is simply no reason for a sunset
with that I urge you to push the red
button to defeat the amendment under
consideration so that we can ensure the
future of granite Advantage thank you
I rise today in support of the residents
of our state who make between 100
percent and 138 percent of the federal
poverty level those who aren't disabled
aren't pregnant when they enter the
program who aren't of retirement age and
don't have children to qualify them for
traditional Medicaid
Medicaid expansion serves a far smaller
group of people than your emails may
suggest
this is a group of people who haven't
traditionally been included in safety
nets in 2010 the Affordable Care Act
shifted the HealthCare Marketplace such
that we can hardly today recognize what
we had only a decade and a half ago
we see most doctors moving into Hospital
Systems to survive the complexity
introduced into the system
the unaffordable Care Act created
Medicaid expansion as a way to address
the problems it created and the group of
granite Staters served by this program
really have no other Solutions today
our state took a half step to move
towards this program in 2014 and fully
engage with Medicaid expansion in 2018.
this program is still relatively new and
that's why I support a six-year Sunset
so that this program can continue with
appropriate legislative attention
now you all may have heard some
arguments that we've already had an
opportunity to review this program
in a normal world that might make sense
but at the years since 2018 been normal
we saw the world shut down in March 2020
at the same time the federal government
prohibited States from removing anybody
from Medicaid and Medicaid expansion
until the expiration of the public
health emergency which ended seven days
ago
this is still a very shifting landscape
and it is far too early to make this
program permanent
if you look at the language that would
be made permanent there are several
sections that are outdated some refer to
dates in 2019 for a waiver request there
are other ones that are not currently in
effect
if we're going to make it permanent
shouldn't we make the language of the
law in good language in order to make it
permanent
with a six-year Sunset and a
re-establishment of the committee that
addresses Medicaid expansion we have a
good reason to do the hard work required
in order to make this program the best
Granite solution we can
without a sunset there'll be a much
higher hurdle to make this program the
best that it can be
I asked for your support for this
amendment to create a six-year Sunset
and otherwise match the language that is
in the budget
we are our careful attention to this
matter to the tens of thousands of
granite Staters who participate in the
granite Advantage program and we can do
that best by passing the six-year sunset
so this time frame is actually a sweet
spot for the Managed Care Organization
contracts five years gives you the best
cost while still having the flexibility
to renegotiate future contracts to look
at the landscape
five years ago nobody had heard of covid
now nobody hasn't heard of it the world
changes and we don't want to make things
permanent I think a five-year contract
would be the best way to serve the
people of the state
so we can best serve our constituents by
passing the six-year sunset
and I urge you to support this amendment
and Mr Speaker I asked for a roll call
vote
the motion the motion before us is ought
to pass
on floor Amendment 1910 a roll call has
been requested is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
the motion before us is floor Amendment
this is a roll call vote care recognizes
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that Senate Bill 263 unamended
is supported by a large Coalition of
organizations with direct interests in
promoting the health of granite Staters
and by countless individual Granite
Staters
and if I know that Senate Bill 263
unamended
promotes Access to Health Care a healthy
Workforce and reduces uncompensated care
and cost shifting
and finally if I know that
the granite Advantage program has
already been in existence for longer
than the six-year Amendment proposed
and that a six-year Amendment
still does not provide the kind of
permanence that allows for long-term
investment in health care infrastructure
would I now press the red button to
do you recognize the representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that tens of
thousands of our fellow citizens rely on
this important Health Care Program
and Mr Speaker if I also know that there
was an understandable concern about a
two-year Sunset being proposed earlier
because of the cost of such a short-term
contract and the likely unwillingness of
Managed Care organizations to bid on it
and that was why a six-year Sunset is
now being proposed because a five-year
contract or longer is more desirable
and Mr Speaker
if I know that the health care industry
is a very Dynamic one which is
constantly changing and that the needs
of the people it serves are always
changing also
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
many hundreds of bills are considered by
this legislature every single year and
that a sunset for this program ensures
that we will give this very important
program the review and attention it very
much deserves and makes certain it
doesn't get buried by all of the other
proposed legislation then Mr Speaker
when I press the green button and pass
this amendment thank you
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1910 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposer press the red button
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
184 voting a 192 voting a the amendment
fails
it's on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative
Zenith Cushman offers floor Amendment
which I recognize representative Cushman
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise before you to speak in support of
amendment one eight six four-h to Senate
Bill 263 a vital amendment that aligns
the commission to evaluate the
effectiveness and future of the New
Hampshire Granite Advantage Health Care
Program with RSA 14 colon 49
which relates to legislative committees
and commissions
this amendment ensures that the
commission adheres to the legislative
intent by limiting its membership to no
more than 15 members with a majority of
those members being legislators
under this amendment the three senators
and three House Representatives will be
the only voting members while
non-legislative members will serve in an
advisory role providing valuable input
without voting privileges
the proposed amendment reflects the
original structure of the commission
where all members were part of the
decision-making process
but only legislators possess the ability
to cast votes
by returning to this model we uphold the
principle of legislative oversight and
ensure that elected official officials
who are accountable to their
constituents have the final say in
shaping the granite Advantage Health
Care Program
one of the significant considerations in
making this change is the potential
conflict of interest that may arise when
non-legislative members particularly
those with a direct State stake in
Medicaid funding hold voting power
within the commission
for example we have representatives of
Managed Care organizations mcos
appointed to the commission
these or currently these organizations
are awarded contracts as vendors under
the Medicaid Managed Care Program
granting voting rights to MCO
Representatives who depend on Medicaid
funding
for their operations raises concerns
about a possible conflict of interests
it is essential to maintain the
integrity and object objectivity of the
commission's decision-making process
ensuring that the interests of the
program's beneficiaries in the overall
Public Welfare are safeguarded
furthermore the proposed amendment
preserves the important role of
non-legis legislator members by
appointing them to serve in an advisory
capacity
their expertise and perspectives will
still be sought after as they possess
valuable insight and knowledge related
to the Health Care public health and the
specific challenges faced by the granite
their contributions will be invaluable
in shaping policy and improving the
program's Effectiveness in light of
these considerations Amendment 1864 H
strikes a balance between ensuring
legislative oversight and harnessing the
expertise of non-legislator members it
maintains the integrity and transparency
of the commission while preventing
potential conflicts of interest
that could arise from allowing certain
non-egislator members to vote on matters
related to Medicaid funding
let us not forget that the primary
purpose of the commission to evaluate
the effectiveness and future of the New
Hampshire Granite Advantage Health Care
Program is to assess and improve the
program ensuring that it fulfills the
intended goals of providing accessible
and Quality Health Care to our citizens
by clarifying the rules of voting and
advisory members through this amendment
we reinforce the commitment to a fair
and impartial evaluation process that
prioritizes the well well-being of our
constituents
in conclusion I urge you each and every
one of you to support Amendment 1864 to
Senate Bill 263 by aligning the
commission with RSA 1449 and restricting
voting rights to legislators who uphold
the principles of legislative oversight
and mitigate potential conflict of
interest
together let us ensure the effectiveness
and sustainability of the Granite
Advantage Healthcare program while
maintaining the highest standards of
accountability and public trust thank
you for your attention and I encourage
you to vote in favor of amendment 1864 H
and Mr Speaker I request a roll call
vote
thank you
there's a question requester roll calls
that's officially seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
um
clear
the motion before us is
on a pass on floor Amendment one eight
six four this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button the boarding
stations are open for 30 seconds
oh
my mistake
uh
this is a roll call vote in the chair
recognized representative Weber for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that Senate Bill 263 on
amended is supported by a large
Coalition of organizations with direct
interests in promoting the health of all
Granite Staters and by countless
individual Granite Staters
if I know that Senate Bill 263 unamended
promotes Access to Health Care a healthy
Workforce and reduces uncompensated care
costs and cost shifting
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that a
commission does not vote on anything
except recommendations which are
recommendations to this body
and that members of Industry sit on
advisory commissions regularly without
any conflict of interest would I now
press the red button
chair recognize representative Cushman
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment brings the commission to
evaluate the effectiveness and future of
the New Hampshire granted Advantage
Health Care Program into compliance with
state law and if I know that it ensures
continued valuable input from
stakeholders while also ensuring elected
officials who are accountable to the to
their constituents have the
decision-making power would I support
this amendment by pressing the green
button
now I'll try this once again
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment one eight six four it's a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposal
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
representative Levitt members must be in
wall members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend to say to the
vote
181 voting 899 voting a the
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative hole offers floor
Amendment 1749
the house will be in order
today I Rise before you to address an
important issue that affects the
well-being of our citizens and the
sustainability of our health care System
the implementation of work requirements
for Medicaid recipients
I firmly believe that introducing work
requirements can bring positive changes
to our society and I urge my colleagues
to consider the benefits this policy can
offer you see
Medicaid was established as a safety net
program to provide Health Care access to
the most vulnerable members of our
society
it was never intended to be a long-term
solution or permanent dependency for
able-bodied individuals
implementing work requirements is a
crucial step towards fostering
self-sufficiency
personal growth and individual
empowerment
by introducing work requirements
we are encouraging Medicaid recipients
to actively participate in the workforce
gain valuable job skills and ultimately
Achieve Financial Independence
meaningful employment not only helps
individuals support themselves and their
families but it also Fosters a sense of
dignity and self-worth which can
significantly contribute to their
overall well-being
furthermore work requirements align with
the principles of fairness and
accountability
our hard-working taxpayers fund Medicaid
and it is our
responsibility to ensure that these
resources are utilized appropriately and
efficiently
by incorporating work requirements we
are promoting a sense of responsibility
and reciprocity among recipients
ensuring that taxpayer dollars are
utilized to support those who genuinely
need assistance
critics argue
that work requirements may lead to loss
of coverage and hinder access to health
care for some individuals however
it's important to note that vulnerable
populations such as those with
disabilities
elderly individuals
pregnant women and caretakers of young
children are covered by traditional
Medicaid and not Medicaid expansion
work requirements have already
demonstrated their effectiveness in
other social programs such as snap
Studies have shown
that individuals subject to work
requirements experience improved
employment outcomes increased earnings
and reduced dependence on public
assistance
it is only logical to extend these
successful principles to the Medicaid
Program where similar positive results
can be expected
to address concerns about access to
health care we must also focus on
creating an environment that facilitates
job growth
vocational training
and Workforce Development by investing
in job creation initiatives vocational
programs and educational opportunities
we can Empower Medicaid recipients to
transition from Reliance on public
assistance to meaningful employment
all while maintaining access to
necessary Health Care Services
in conclusion
implementing work requirements for
Medicaid recipients
is not about punishing or abandoning
those in need
it's about promoting personal growth
promoting and fostering self-sufficiency
and ensuring the sustainability of our
health care System
by encouraging able-bodied individuals
to actively participate in the workforce
we are empowering them to reach their
full potential reducing dependency on
public assistance and creating a
stronger more resilient Society
I urge my colleagues
to support this amendment
recognizing the transformative impact it
can have on the lives of our citizens
and the long-term viability of our
health care System
push the green button on Amendment 1749
h
R speaker I request a roll call thank
that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vault is a member yield to
questions
one question remember yields you may
inquire
[Music]
had a waiver request but that time is
expired is there a reason it's important
for us to make sure that we are having a
thank you for your question
representative
um yes we had work requirements in place
previously but they've been overturned
and not in place today however in
Washington DC they are talking about
this issue right now and possibly
most likely
implementing work requirements so we
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1749 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Weber
now the chair recognized representative
Weber for a parliamentary inquiry
speaker
speaker if I know that SB 263 is meant
unamended is supported by a large
Coalition of organizations with direct
interests in promoting the health of
granite Staters and by countless
individual Granite Staters
if I know that Senate Bill 263 unamended
promotes Access to Health Care a healthy
Workforce and reduces uncompensated care
costs and cost shifting
if I further know that the experience of
the program is that 70 of the recipients
are already working
and that many of the other recipients
use this program as a short-term
transition between one job or another or
as a way to cover recovery from an
illness that has cost them to lose their
job
do you recognize representative Bill
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know Studies have shown
individuals subject to work requirements
experience improved employment outcomes
increased earnings and reduced
dependence on public assistance and Mr
Speaker if I know this amendment is not
about punishing or abandoning these
those in need
and Mr Speaker if I know this amendment
is about promoting personal growth
fostering self-sufficiency
and ensuring the sustainability of our
health care System
and if I know America was founded on and
operates on a system of checks and
balances would I now press the green
button to approve this amendment thank
you Mr Speaker
motion before us is the floor Amendment
1749 it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your pulse or press a red button voting
well members president an opportunity to
186 148 193 voting a
committee Amendment fails I mean the
Lord Amendment fails what reason is a
member rise
a rise to make a motion State your
motion uh Mr Speaker I understand that
we have to be out of here by four
o'clock I see some bills on the consent
calendar would it be inappropriate at
this point in time to ask to table
Senate bill 263.
motion is in order
the motion before us is a table Senate
bill 263.
the motion before is just the table
Senate bill 263. this is going to be a
division vote chair recognizes
representative hunt for a parliamentary
inquiry
if I know the house has already taken a
position on this bill in house bill 2.
if I know that the Senate has any
disagreement that will be taken up in
the in the committee conference
if I know that we do have a couple more
bills we need to get through they're on
the consent calendar and I know we need
to be out of here or otherwise we're
going to be stuck here all night while
there's a road race will I now
will I now vote Yes on the pending
motion
gee I recognize representative Weber for
a parliamentary inquiry
no the Senate built
Bill free unamended
is supported by a large Coalition of
and by countless individuals branded
Staters
and if I know that Senate Bill 263
unamended promotes Access to Health Care
a healthy Workforce and reduces
uncompensated care costs and cost
shifting
and finally if I know that we have been
told that the members of this court will
be allowed out whenever we finish our
business but that our constituents
wanted us to vote on this bill amended
would I now resolve to stay to The
Bitter End hope that some of the people
offering amendments will think better of
it and press the red button
the motion before us is the table house
bill Senate bill 263.
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
well members president an opportunity to
185 owning a 196.49 the tabling motion
fails
the bill is on second reading open to
further Amendment representative who
will office floor Amendment one eight
six nine and for what reason is the
point of order of question to the chair
inquiry of the chair
inquire yeah we've just heard two
different people one say that we have to
be out here at four o'clock another one
says there's no uh time limit could you
give us what the correct uh answer to
the problem we have is the road race
actually starts at six
but the roads are going to be closed
down before that
for what reason to memorize
question of the chair
question were we not sent to
communication
yesterday via email saying that
it depends on
where where you're parked and what time
I mean everybody in store Street will
certainly be able to get out the people
around here
bills on secondary and open to further
Amendment
representative wool office floor
Amendment one eight six nine and
representative wholes recognized the
speech
for those who haven't found it in their
cluster of amendments I'm going to read
the entire thing because it's only one
line long
amend the bill by inserting after
section 7 the following and renumbering
the original Section 8 to read as nine
repeal 2018 if this is chapter law
342-20 relative to the severability of
the New Hampshire Medicaid and premium
what is a severability clause quite
simply when laws are put together if a
court strikes down a section of it
unless there's a severability clause in
place
potentially the whole thing is at risk
at the time that this bill was put
forward there was an open window for
work requirements that window closed
after our former president was no longer
in office
that work requirements is front page
news in DC right now what we are seeing
going going on is the house under
speaker McCarthy
I think I'm allowed to the the U.S
speaker
um has pushed very hard to re-establish
our president is pushed back we don't
know the outcome of that but we do know
that it would be valuable to put back
into law that Clause such that the
program is contingent upon having work
requirements
as the former speaker talked about work
requirements and the benefits and I want
to concur with her remarks
this is not to be a handout this is to
be a hand up this program this is
supposed to be temporary
two weeks ago I sat on as a as a
substitute on HHS
to talk about this bill
and we agreed at the time that those who
are participating in the program this is
not a lifestyle choice this is not a
permanent decision this is to be a
transitory event
I personally experienced one of those I
lost my job at one point four kids at
home
no work
I understand firsthand that you need
medical insurance you need food you need
to make mortgage payments I've seen that
I've lived that heck one year we our
family lived below the federal poverty
limit
I understand what families have to go
through
but with that said the goal was not to
live there that wasn't the destination
the destination was to get out of that
situation and to get ahead
what we want is we want to make sure
that the program is established and set
up such that those who are trying to
live off of this and take advantage of
it are not in a position to do so but
those who want to use this program as a
stepping stone to get ahead are allowed
to do so I would ask that you would
support floor Amendment whatever number
the motion before us is floor Amendment
roll call has been requested Senator
Cushman is that sufficiently seconded it
is sufficiently seconded members take
the motion before us is floor Amendment
one eight six nine this is a roll call
vote which I recognizes representative
speaker
if I know that Senate bills 263
unamended is supported by a large
Coalition of organizations with direct
interests in promoting the health of
granite Staters
and by countless individual states
Granite Staters rather if I know that
Senate Bill 263 unamended promotes
Access to Health Care a healthy
Workforce and reduces uncomplicated care
and cost shifting and if I further know
that this program is working just fine
as it is with no further adjustments
necessary would I now push the red
button
chair recognize representative turkon
when turquoit for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this amendment would only
remove the severability Clause from
existing chapter law
would I now press the green button thank
you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is for Amendment
1869 is the roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
is on
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
194 voting a 195 voting a
floor Amendment fails
I'm going to ask that members please
stay in your seats we're losing three to
five minutes every time we have a roll
call vote and I would assume the other
23 or 24 amendments we have are going to
be roll call division votes
so the more you're in your seats the
less we have to chase you in the
hallways the quicker we'll get done
for what reason is to memorize for a
motion Mr Speaker
motion I moved to lay SB 263 on the
table
a roll call has been requested
I assume that's not seconded
this will be a division vote
the motion before us is a
floor to lay
chair recognizes the representative
Alexander for a parliamentary inquiry
we're good go ahead thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know the house has
already taken a position on this issue
and if I know that I parked the
Legislative Office Building garage and I
know that my car will not be allowed out
until the late evening where they then
press the green button to lay this bill
also be in order
chair recognize the representative Weber
is supported by a large Coalition of
organizations with direct interests in
promoting the health of all Granite
Staters and by countless individual
Granite Staters
if I know that Senate Bill 263 unamended
promotes Access to Health Care a healthy
Workforce and reduces uncompensated care
costs and cost shifting
and if I know that the provisions in the
budget Bill were a compromise and that
many of us here wish to vote for this
bill without a Sunset and that we are
willing to stay here for as long as it
takes to get to that vote would I now
press the red button the house will be
the motion before us
is the tabling motion on Senate bill
263.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposed you'll press the red button
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
1985 voting a 194 voting a
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment Senator pelosov or if it's
floor Amendment one eight four one
chair recognize the representative
pelosov
thank you Mr Speaker
I listened support of amendment 1841 h
uh this language adds that at the time
of enrollment
we acknowledge and the utilization of
benefits uh so it is out and termination
of benefits and for the purpose of this
section we Define
narrowly on the utilization of benefits
as one anal
physical examination with a licensed
primary provider within one year from
the date of enrollment or anal
re-enrollment
they say no physical examination
frequency may be extended first if the
last visited primary care provided
developed a care plan that does not
require a physical examination visit in
a given time frame or second if the
individual made all reasonable steps to
schedule a physical examination
appointment but was not able to get it
scheduled in a given time frame for
reasons beyond the individual control
uh this uh amendment is a result of
bipartisan discussion it brings together
suggestions from both spiders and it
enforces and encourages regular physical
examinations It Is by patches and
understanding of the house Health Human
Services and then the Affairs committee
that regular physicals are extremely
useful the useful to provide from
catastrophic Healthcare results that may
it's quiet now it wasn't
member may continue
thank you Mr Speaker
so those physicals are extremely useful
to avoid catastrophic results and
unpaid medical bills and that's why
both parties support it and for example
uh we put a amendment that if individual
made all reasonable
steps to schedule an appointment but was
not able it excuses it from this
amendment and I ask you to put a green
button to support this amendment is the
member yield the questions yeah yes
memory yields
thank you Mr speaker thank you thank you
representative for taking my question uh
why is it hard to get an appointment
does the federal pandemic response have
thank you for the question
yes last two years it's a crisis in
healthcare with a Workforce and uh
we are getting uh plenty of federal
funds but those federal funds come with
mandates that destroy our health care
Force those vaccine mandates first some
health care workers to live because they
don't want to inject themselves with
this ineffective and unsafe medication
and some medical healthcare workers were
actually injured by this medications
some people contracted covet but Federal
requirements to treat covet were also
extremely harmful to those medical
professionals who got infected was
covered from their patients for example
you all know that first recommendation
was to put on oxygen intubation as early
as possible now we know that yes if we
need oxygen to breathe but too much
oxygen too early in this illness causes
more harm than good
the same as the representative I think
has answered the question
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker honorable members of the
house I rise in support of 1841.
this amendment requires a minimum
utilization of benefits to remain
eligible for the granted Advantage
Health Care Program
it defies the minimum utilization
benefits as an annual physical
requirement we will licensed primary
care physician
the amendment allows for flexibility
including cases
that the existing plan does not require
one
Managed Care organizations are
reimbursed for enrolled members whether
they utilize the program or not
the primary goal of Managed Care
organizations is to encourage people to
schedule and attend their primary
physical
the primary care visit is needed to
reduce the overall cost of the health
care and reduce the uncompensated care
this is why this amendment is necessary
the amendment ensures that we have
this leverage to ensure Primary Care
visits this amendment adds
responsibility
and adds protection for the taxpayer
in conclusion it is important that the
resources are not Unlimited even when
subsidized by federal funds
when we waste Federal resources we take
it away from the people who need it
just imagine how we could spend on
this amendment encourages Primary Care
visits reduces catastrophic Health
outcomes overall cost of Health Care and
uncompensated costs for these reasons
please press the green button and adopt
representative Sweeney has asked for a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
members take your seats and also be in
order
for what reason did member rise
we're in we're in we're in the voting
mode right now
okay
State your question
to the chair thank you for taking it
is it diliatory for a member to get up
and say the same thing over and over
again we've already heard it
it's up to the member
for what they give for a pi if I feel
it's out of
bounds I will call them on it but right
now they haven't said anything
that I would write out of bounds so I
think that's your answer
[Music]
right now in front of us is floor
this is a roll call vote chair recognize
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
[Music]
Mr Speaker if I know that Senate Bill
263 unamended promotes Access to Health
Care a healthy Workforce and reduces
uncompensated carrier costs and cost
shifting
if I also know that we are proceeding
only on parliamentary inquiries and not
with debate so couldn't possibly be seen
to be dilatory
but if I know
that to require a specific medical
procedure of a person without their
consent is unconstitutional
and finally if I know that for anybody
who has had to reschedule an appointment
for anything as for example when the
house meets when your appointment was
set for
and I know how long it takes to
reschedule appointments
would I now see the lack of wisdom of
jerich and I was representative Carol
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know I promise to say this only one
time
and if I know that it's completely
reasonable to require accountability
from individuals receiving benefits paid
for by the hard-working taxpayer
and if I know that when an individual
has not used their benefits
it's completely reasonable
to assume the benefit may not be needed
by that person
and if I know this amendment addresses
concerns
that individuals might have difficulty
scheduling an appointment with their
primary care physician annually
and to address the previous Pi if I know
that this amendment also addresses
concerns that there are individuals who
may not need an appointment
with their PCP annually
and finally Mr Speaker
if I know that's the duty of every
person in this room
to assure the taxpayers of New Hampshire
that they are not paying for individuals
who are not using their benefits
then when I press the green button to
pass this amendment thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is floor Amendment one
eight four one it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
members president of an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment chair recognize the
representative splane office floor
Amendment 1890
what reason is a member rise uh yes Mr
Speaker I'd like to be recognized for a
motion State your motion I would like to
it is a proper motion what a state your
point of order
[Music]
motion detail
members have complained when members on
our side have simply done a pi and
they've said it was dilatory is it not
dilatory to move to Table after every
single motion I understand that it is an
appropriate motion but is it not in this
the motion is in order
thank you I'm not going to question
the member or any member on making a
proper motion so the motion before us is
Senate bill
263.
division has been requested members take
represent
ative yeah
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 263 this is a division vote
care recognizes representative Berry for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that SB 263
is opposed by a large Coalition of
organizations with a direct interest in
promoting the health of all grain of
saters and if I know that Senate Bill
263 unamended creates a potential
long-term financial obligation for the
state and reduces our ability and
flexibility to craft budgets in the
future a future where we may not know
the circumstances around revenues and Mr
Speaker if I know that the provisions in
the budget Bill were a compromise which
we should honor and that many of us here
wish to uphold that historic bipartisan
Voice vote and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that many of the members here are
willing to stay all night to uphold that
bipartisan Voice vote would I now press
do you recognize representative Weber
thank you Mr Speaker
if just as the last two times I voted
not to table and I still don't want a
table would I press the red button
motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 263 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
okay
[Music]
representative
yeah
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
182 voting a 192 voting a the motion to
table fails bills on second reading open
to further Amendment representative
spleen office floor Amendment 1890
for what reason house will be in order
I'd like to make a motion
State your motion I'd like to reconsider
members I Rise to offer
floor Amendment 1898.
which
adds a few lines
recognizing that
addiction is an Insidious disease and I
think that probably not a single member
in this chamber has escaped the last 10
years without knowing somebody or having
someone in their family who's had to
struggle with addiction
under our current state of things I
think that it's only fair that we
address that
in this bill
acknowledges the fact that addiction
recovery
it's not quiet enough
addiction recovery is not just freeing
oneself from the addiction but it's also
building your self-esteem and job
qualifications back up again so that you
can feel valued and stay free of
addiction
and so this amendment will add lines
that say that the substance use disorder
treatment or recovery activities and or
mental health treatment under the
subparagraph shall be credited against
the requirement for work
for the first three months on an hour
for hour basis but on the subsequent
months every two hours she'll be
credited as one hour of community
engagement and this is an incentive to
after those first three months of
intensive drug rehabilitation or mental
health rehabilitation
to have the person start working on
their career
their work opportunities and to start
building back that self-esteem that is
going to be so critical to being able to
maintain a a free of addiction lifestyle
going forward
so I would urge you all to support this
amendment and push green thank you
remember yield the questions
I'll take one
thank you
several weeks ago in this chamber we
heard someone testify at the end on a
matter of personal privilege
how getting help from a program was
instrumental in their life
is the amendment that you have before
something that's going to help more
yes thank you for the question because
yes it does it has been proven by facts
that somebody who goes successfully
through a treatment program but then
faces no work prospects and or a
devalued self-worth when they come out
of the program
then tends to fall back into those same
patterns of addiction whereas if they
have built back that self-esteem and
they have worked towards work prospects
before I call Representative love up
I want to let everybody know that you're
safe to where you are parked
we will get you out when we're done with
session whether that be an hour from now
or six hours from now I don't know
but we will get you out
and is also we have a lot of snacks in
the back room
we still got about 20 amendments to go
a roll call has been requested who
requested the roll call roll call has
been requested is that sufficiently
hello
thank you
the motion before us is floor Amendment
care recognizes representative explain
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
addiction and mental health problems are
an Insidious problem within our culture
right now and that
recovery is not successful unless the
person has built back their self-esteem
if I know that tapering off after three
months to allow the work requirement to
only be partially implemented so that
they can start working on self-esteem
building and job prospects is is a way
towards success would I then push the
do you recognize representative Weber
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I firmly support both work
and substance abuse treatment
and agree with much that's been said
about the value of both treatment and
work
but if I know and bemused because the
work requirement
contained in the statute has been held
unconstitutional or at least
inappropriate I that's I used the wrong
word but I'm getting tired
and so
there is no work requirement to credit
against
and I hope people will remember that
with the further amendments on the work
requirement would I now press the red
button
the motion before us is floor Amendment
one eight nine o
it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button Wellness nations are open
come up or thumb down representative
McKay
ER
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
75 voting a 194 voting a
Amendment fails
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative who will office floor
Amendment 1750.
okay
excuse me question of the chair State
your question
okay there is a quorum in the room thank
you
member of maple seed I think
it's quieted enough in here now
going to take us five minutes to get
okay
Amendment 1750
for those who think that
it's not fair that those floor
amendments brought up I sat in this
committee I had these amendments drafted
prior to the executive session we talked
about some of these but the day that I
was there as a sub
we were not able to vote on these
these were submitted to the clerk prior
to the calendar and I did that for a
reason I wanted everybody who was here
as a member to have a chance to read the
Amendments before we got to the floor
I think that's valuable that's playing
Fair
while I may not agree with the views of
my colleagues on the other side I at
least wanted to have a discussion about
some of the fundamental flaws that are
we would be wise
to not set up not establish a program
that goes on for infant for whatever
infini
that doesn't have the appropriate
safeguards
this is one of those things
that's a safeguard that's necessary
I don't know if any of you have had to
go to the doctor recently
going to the doctor right now is hard
going to the doctor is months worth of
waiting
that is fundamentally created by several
issues
the first of which is we have it in
inadequate staff in the state in the
medical field
unfortunately we can't fix that
we also happen to have inadequate access
to hospitals meaning there's not enough
hospital rooms
this program this amendment can do
something about it
and lastly
we are crushing our private Health Care
industry
and I'll say that again we are crushing
the Private health care industry the
small mom and pop shops
that do the services that help people
get the medications they need to solve
the problems
are getting pushed out of business
this amendment solves that
I would ask that you would support this
amendment and I'm going to ask for a
roll call vote because it's it's
important
that we Preserve
access to Private health care it's
important that we start
or sorry that we end the protectionism
that we do for the hospitals around the
state that gives them this 15-mile
buffer that no other hospitals can be
built
and we start allowing a better free
market Health Care system I asked for a
roll call vote they ask that you support
sure
remember yields
thank you for taking my question I'm
aware that we have a shortage of
hospital beds here in New Hampshire and
I believe these critical access
hospitals only have 25 beds is
preserving them helping us to meet the
health care needs of granite Staters or
is this artificially eliminating the
by enabling this what's known as the
critical Access Health Care Hospital
provision right we've artificially
created locations that can't have
additional beds
that shuts down the ability for people
to get the health care they need
as I said we would be wise to protect
the two things that are crucial to
making sure Granite Staters have the
health care access they need one is
expanding Hospital access and two is
making sure we don't crush our private
thank you speaker members of the House
so I was talking to Jr about this
representative Howell sorry
and I related my own personal story of
when I cut my hand down to the bone
doing some construction work
and how ended up costing eighteen
hundred dollars for nine stitches
they gave me a break because I don't
have insurance so it was twelve hundred
dollars but the the fact that there's no
competition in the marketplace for
medical care is just so detrimental and
we have this idea that we have to
we have to farm out our decision making
to the federal government on this this
topic is so detrimental to what we're
doing we need to focus on keeping it
here within the state and not
relying on the federal government to
take care of our needs nothing good
comes out of the federal government
nothing really let's be honest here we
have no control over them at least like
today
when we have protests also be in order
people can at least come here
representative
we don't
make accusations of that nature on this
floor
of what nature speaker
the accusations you just made that
nothing good comes out of the federal
government that might be your personal
opinion but that's not an accusation I
I'm going to allow on the floor
very few good things come out of the
federal government and I'm concerned
about that and I would like to have more
control at the local level so point
being
the more competition we have in the
medical field the better off we are and
it wouldn't cost over a hundred dollars
per Stitch
it's just common sense
so yes anyway I'm in support of this
amendment and I hope that we can start
really focusing on what needs to be done
and that's keeping decision making local
and not relying on some federal
bureaucrats to solve our problems which
they will never do never have done
motion before this is floor Amendment
a roll call has been requested
presented Sweeney requests a roll call
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1750 it's a roll call vote
chair recognized the representative
thank you
Mr Speaker
if I know that expanding Health Care
opportunities and competition only
improves the overall access and quality
of care
if I know that removing the control that
critical access hospitals have over free
market growth will allow for the
expansion of Health Care opportunities
if I know
that allowing clients opportunities to
make Health Care decisions with their
own hard-earned dollars will be
empowered to take control over their own
health outcomes would I press the green
button to allow greater Health Care
freedom in the granite state
chair recognize representative Weber for
speaker
pairing critical access hospitals to
choose between having more competition
right near them
or not serving
Granite Advantage customers who are not
going to be able to pay the fees at
those new facilities
but which will be impacted on the
critical care hospitals
would I now press the red button because
this does not increase access to health
care and does not increase access to
health care for the population we're
talking about thank you
motion before us the floor Amendment
1750 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposed or press the red button
[Music]
represent gagne
what's up wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will
169 148 192 voting a committee Amendment
fails
for what reason does member rise
Mr Speaker what would be the effect of
emotion uh
the effect would be that we would
continue to take up the amendments
and there would be roll calls and pis
only
motion is in order
and a division vote has been requested
it is
it is sufficiently seconded so this will
be a roll call vote
is this house will be in order is this a
debatable motion no it's not
speaker the question of the chair please
it's a question what exactly are we
we're moving the previous question what
on the underlying bill so we're voting
to vote on the bill as unamended
no no we're taking up the rest of the
amendments but they're going to be roll
calls with pis only
and women's debate it limits debate yes
this every does everybody understand the
if this motion passes
then we'll take up each one of the
Amendments as we've been doing only they
will be limited if this will limit
so this is limiting debate
question
thank you for taking my question Mr
Speaker I've never seen this before
while on the floor not saying I haven't
seen it um my question is for some of
these amendments they're technical in
nature how do we cover the content of an
amendment in only a pi
yeah
that's the purpose of the vote right now
the question before the house is move
the previous question the chair
recognize representative Weber for
if I would like very much to proceed now
without lengthy debates on each of these
further amendments
but would like to see each of the
Amendments that anybody chooses to bring
up
get a vote
do you recognize representative Sweeney
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
New Hampshire house has a proud
bipartisan and historic tradition of
allowing debate between members on any
topic that comes up and further Mr
Speaker if I know uh then maybe not in
this session but in past session other
attempts to limit debate on bills have
been widely and bipartisanly rejected by
both sides so we can have the debate
that's needed would I now press the red
button and preserve the traditions of
this bipartisan New Hampshire house to
continue to have the debates that we
need to have today thank you
motion before us is to move the previous
question
this is a role called
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
[Music]
representative coulon Jan Brandon Tripp
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
under 96 voting a 169 voting a the
representative
bills on Second Amendment open to
further Amendment
representative Phillips office floor
president Sweeney has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before is floor Amendment
Jay recognizes representative Phyllis
yeah I
um
if I know that the
Granite State I'm sorry Granite
Advantage Health Care Program has no
work requirement for pregnant persons
and this amendment would
remove that and lift the work
requirement at 36 weeks gestation
therefore encouraging women to stay in
the workforce and
not provide
sorry
if I know that by not passing this
amendment we are making a stay-at-home
mother a paid position and it should not
be subsidized by the government would I
press the house would be an order
Mr Speaker when I press the green button
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
understand that there is currently no
work requirement under the granted
advantaged Health Care Program so this
amendment is not needed would I push the
red button
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1860 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your poster press the red button
[Music]
Palmer was president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
175 voting 894 voting a the amendment
fails
those on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative who lost his floor
representative Sweeney has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
motion before us is floor Amendment 1748
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Karen
thank you Mr Speaker seeing that we are
unable to debate
this amendment it is in regards to those
in the program to have semi-annual drug
testing to continue in the program
unless they are in a substance abuse
program
if I know that resources are finite and
drug screens can help contain cost and
if I know that substance misuse disorder
leads to underemployment drug screens
can put people on the path to recovery
and success
also if I know that drug screens are
parts of millions of workers employment
contracts it is certainly
reasonable to expect participants to
participate in drug screens and lastly
if I know that the people of New
Hampshire deserve better than National
Health Care would I press the green
button thank you
do you recognize representative Weber
the addiction addiction to treatment
is a key component of the granted
Advantage Program
and if I know that while people are
receiving treatment they often slip and
fall and they need to get up and go back
to treatment
would I then press the red button so as
not to defeat the soul core purpose of
the motion before is the floor Amendment
it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
representative
C
Burnham
awesome well members president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 to say
the 73 voting 895 voting a
those on second reading open to further
Amendment Senator Glenn turcotte office
floor Amendment 1881
Representatives Sweeney has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
motion before us is the floor Amendment
one eight eight one
chair recognized representative Lynn
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know current administrative rules
contained in several of the rules
describe the opportunity to cure a
deficit in the number of hours worked
and Community engagement hours
and if I also know that if an individual
fails to complete the required number of
hours in one month they have the ability
to make those hours up in the following
month
and if I also know that a problem exists
with that
the administrative rules as they are
written would promote permit that
individual to actually reach a rolling
level of deficit
of 100 hours while still being eligible
for Medicaid expansion
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
the change in this amendment would allow
the recipient recipient of Medicaid to
work in community engagement activities
up to 160 hours a month rather than the
current 100 hour limitation contained in
the rules would I then vote green to
pass this amendment thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognized representative Weber
for a parliamentary inquiry
this amendment is not only unnecessary
but irrelevant would I now press the red
button
the motion before us is for Amendment
one eight eight one this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed or press
the red button voting stages are open
well members president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 state
106 76 voting a 193 voting a the
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative who will office floor
representative Sweeney has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members stay in your
seats
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1747 chair recognizer representative
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this amendment is on page 34
in the calendar
I know I can't read it but I can at
least talk about the highlights right
now
if I know that the critical sentence
that is in this amendment talks about
making sure people either are working
or getting help through Unemployment
Security and actively participating in
the program
if I further know that this program is
intended to be a way to help people get
ahead
and that by having them go to
Unemployment Security they can gain the
skills necessary to get ahead what I now
which I recognize representative Weber
for parliamentary inquiry thank Mr
Speaker this
work require
D already been held on
this program is a health program and not
a work preparation program would I know
that this
amendment makes equally little sense to
add to a health Protection Program and
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1747 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're upholster press the red button
foreign
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend state of
173 voting 894 voting a the amendment
fails
yeah
all righty the Bill's on second reading
and open a further Amendment
representative Drago moves four
Amendment one eight three two
representative Sweeney requests a roll
of calls that's sufficiently seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
the question is on floor Amendment
1a32h and this is a roll call vote
representative Drago is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that I had a great speech
planned that I am no longer allowed to
share
and if I know that the rule-making
authority belongs with the legislator
because we were elected to represent our
constituents and our state and if I know
that we are a volunteer legislator and
many of us still hold full-time jobs
and if I know a volunteering or
community service can be done around
work hours and there shall therefore
should not be a qualifying factor for an
entitlement program instead of working
and finally if I know that our economy
depends on a strong Workforce and that
this body should be doing all it can to
keep people working
then would I press a green button in
and a shocking turn of events
representative Weber is recognized for a
Mr Speaker
if I know that the work requirement is
not being enforced
so that this amendment is both
unnecessary and irrelevant but if I also
know that over 70 percent of the
recipients of the Granite Advantage
Program are already working and that for
others this program allows them to
regain their health so they can go back
to work would I now press the red button
questions on floor Amendment one eight
three two H if you're in favor of
adopting the floor Amendment press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
[Music]
panic
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
168 in the affirmative 193 and the
representative Belcher moves floor
Amendment one eight five seven
representative Sweeney requests a roll
call with is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the questions on the adoption of
amendment one eight five seven H and
this is a roll call vote representative
dry is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
if I know
that the amendment
would cause a repeal of RSA 126 double A
and the granite Advantage Health Care
program established there under if the
appropriation from the federal
government fell before low 90 percent
and if I knew
that when two parties enter into an
agreement and one party fails to meet
the conditions of that agreement then
the agreement becomes void
would I press the green button now to
seal the deal
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill is going to travel
from this body to the finance committee
and what we are voting on now is Health
policy and not funding
and if I know that everybody who has
amendments about funding should take
them to the finance committee where they
can be dealt with after an appropriate
the questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment 1-857-h and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
[Music]
Phillips
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
170 in the affirmative 191 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative Belcher moves floor
Amendment one eight five nine H
representative Sweeney requests a roll
call vote is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the question is on the adoption of
amendment 1-859-h and this is a roll
call vote representative dry is
thank you Mr W speaker
if I knew that this bill
provides that if at any time a budgeted
appropriation for the program
is otherwise insufficient to cover the
cost of the program then the RSA and the
grant Advantage Health Care program
established there under would be
repealed after 180 days
and if I know that when the budget for a
program doesn't cover the cost of the
program someone has to pick up the tab
and if I don't want that someone to be
the New Hampshire taxpayer would I then
press the green button now
representative Weber is recognized for
thank you or if I know that we are here
to vote on health policy not funding
issues
and if I know that there will be an
opportunity in the finance commission
committee to address funding after an
appropriate hearing would I now press
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1859-h and this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red button
representative
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote
169 in the affirmative 196 and a
negative the amendment fails
representative turcott moves floor
Amendment one eight six seven eight
representative Sweeney requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members keep it
parked
okay
the question is on the adoption of
amendment 1867-h and this is a roll call
vote representative pleasage is
Mr speaker thank you
I know that the unemployed adults want
to work and be productive and if I know
that this amendment would verify their
120 hours per month of work and
Community activity efforts and be
eligible for the New Hampshire Grant
Advantage Health Care Program benefits
would I now vote Yes by pressing the
green button Mr speaker thank you
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that 70
percent of the recipients of the granted
Advantage Program are already working
and if I know that the work requirement
is not being enforced right now would I
recognize that this amendment is
unnecessary and irrelevant and push the
the questions on the adoption of
amendment
1867h and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red button
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
174 in the affirmative 190 and the
representative turcott moves floor
Amendment
1868-h representative Sweeney requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
uh getting your calisthenics in today
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
the question is is on the adoption of
amendment one eight six eight h
this is a roll call vote
representative turcott is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know the term his or her family
contained in SB 263 is not defined in
either two SB 263 or administrative
rules but the term immediate family
members is extensively defined in
administrative rules
and if I also know that other people
living within the individual's household
such as domestic Partners or unmarried
couples and others should be counted
when assessing an individual's
and finally Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment corrects this technical
deficiency would I now press the green
button thank you Mr Speaker
representative Weber is recognized for
speaker
if I recognize
of family members who may have
absolutely no duty of support for
anybody else in the household
in the computations is unfair and
defeats the purpose of greater access to
health care would I now press the red
button
the questions on the adoption of
amendment one eight six eight H and this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
press the green button if you're opposed
press the red voting stations are open
okay
[Music]
of all members Presidents had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
169 in the affirmative 190 on the
representative you Keller moves floor
Amendment one eight seven zero
representative Sweeney requests a roll
call vote as sufficiently seconded
and again it is this will be a roll call
questions on the adoption of amendment
one eight seven zero H and this is a
roll call vote representative Yokel is
if I know that the language in this
amendment has already been unanimously
adopted by this body and that it went
over to the Senate and or the the other
body and um
re-affirm my this body's previous vote
by just
saying that uh
right to know language needs or right to
know is important and that reviewing
non-public meeting minutes is important
and we should uh
adopt this language thank you very much
representative Weber is recognized for
is supported by a large Coalition of
organizations with direct interests in
promoting the health of granite Staters
and by countless individual Granite
Staters and Mr Speaker if I want to vote
on this bill as health care policy
without any attachments would I now
the questions on the adoption of
amendment one eight seven zero H this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
press the green button opposed press the
red
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote thou shall attend to
the state of the vote
166 in the affirmative 194 and the
representative yokelum whose floor
Amendment
1871 and representative Sweeney requests
a roll call as sufficiently seconded
it is their knees are still working this
will be a roll call vote members take
the question is on the adoption of
one eight seven one-h
and this is a roll call Representative
yokella is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
language was also unanimously passed by
this house
and that uh the Senate also chose to not
act on this language would I now vote to
add this language to this Bill thank you
Mr Speaker
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
speaker
the previous
vote was part of a compromise package
and if I know that I want to be able to
vote on this bill unamended and you know
the questions on the adoption of
amendment one eight seven one-h and this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
press the green button if you're opposed
press the red voting stations are open
positions
thumbs up your thumbs down please thank
you
Blaine
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
162 in the affirmative 191 and the
representative Holm whose floor
Amendment 1872 and representative
Sweeney requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it has sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
me
the question is on the adoption of
amendment one eight seven two h
I don't know why they're up but they're
going to have to be sitting or they're
this is a roll call vote
representative holes recognized for
let's quiet a little I'm trying to help
you out by keeping the pace going but I
mean we can go slower while people have
chats behind the seats walk around so
let's just get this done okay
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this amendment does two
things
it has a simple copay for standard
member was recognized for parliamentary
inquiry yeah I'm asking about the
amendment if I know what it does I want
to make sure I explain what it does
since we haven't had the debate on it
nope
if I know that the amendment requires a
25 copay love it
okay if I know that the amendment
further would require a small co-pay to
go to an emergency room
if I know that most of the people who
have Private health care insurance have
similar things required of their health
care programs
what I now support amendment 1872-h
to put on parity those that are part of
this program with those that are funding
this program through the private
workplace thank you
representative Weber is recognized for
that folks who use the granite Advantage
Program have fewer resources than those
who are employed in the kind of jobs
that come with health care
and if I know that this bill is to
promote Access to Health Care
and further if I know that a co-pay of
25 for a medical visit or a hundred
dollars for an emergency room visit is
going to put a roadblock in the way of
these people receiving care would I now
push the red button
questions on the adoption of amendment
one eight seven two H and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
experience
all members presence had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
166 in the affirmative 191 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative turcott moves floor
Amendment
1873h and representative Sweeney
requests a roll calls as sufficiently
seconded
at sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
nice to see everybody getting their
questions on the adoption of amendment
one eight seven three h and this is a
roll call vote
representative Brown's recognized for
so if I'd known
or paid a little more attention to what
representative turkot had asked me the
other day while I was grading my
driveway I probably wouldn't be standing
up here right now doing the pi but
anyway if I know this program is funded
with taxpayer Monies
and if I also know Medicaid expansion
recipients in this bill should meet
their commitments and responsibilities
as outlined
and finally if I believe being
ineligible for benefits
for a period of 12 months is an adequate
incentive
to ensure individuals meet those
commitments would I now press the green
button
representative Webbers recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this program is designed to
promote Access to Health Care
and suspending or disenrolling
individuals
from re-enrolling for 12 months if
they're suspended
preventing individuals from re-enrolling
within 12 months if they are suspended
or disenrolled
really does not promote Access to Health
Care would I now press the red button to
defeat this amendment
questions on the adoption of amendment
1873h this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button if
you're opposed press the red voting
[Music]
representative
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
164 in the affirmative 183 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative McLean moves floor
Amendment
1-897h and representative Sweeney
request a roll calls as sufficiently
seconded
as sufficiently seconded enough strong
bipartisan vote
this will be a roll call of members take
receipts
the questions on the adoption of
amendment one eight nine seven H and
this is a roll call vote representative
McLean's recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that Amendment 1897
H takes a federal no surprises act and
adds to it for those providers that
participate in the grand Advantage
Program
and if I know that Medicaid expansion
was only intended to be a portion of the
Affordable Care Act and that if we make
it permanent without addressing the
weaknesses in the exchanges and pricing
transparency it won't be sustainable in
the long term
and if I know that the federal no
surprises act co-sponsored by one of our
current U.S senators recognizes and
tries to address some of these
deficiencies and if I know that this
amendment Builds on the infrastructure
created while implementing no surprises
to create even greater pricing
transparency would I now press the green
button to show my support thank you Mr
Speaker
representative Weber is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I'm all for Price
transparency but as written this
amendment would absolutely add
incomparable amounts of administrative
cost to any institution that accepts
Granite Advantage patients and does not
add that transparency to any institution
that does not accept Granite Advantage
patients would I worry that this
amendment might have a chilling effect
on institutions accepting Granite
Advantage patients and so would I push
the questions on the adoption of
amendment one eight nine seven H and
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
[Music]
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend the state of the vote
164 in the affirmative 190 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative Christine Perez moves
Amendment 1901 H and representative
Sweeney requests to roll calls as
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
another roll call vote members take your
seats
Sergeant Ram's voices are holding up
clear
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 190 H and this is a roll call
vote representative Christine Perez
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill is not about
money
and not about work but is about the
possibility of saving lives
if I know that this bill
only enhances what was given to the
Commissioners in 2019 with respect to
poly Pharmacy drugs
if I know that the polypharmacy drug is
the use of multiple drugs by one person
with also it could be supplements for
many many different types of illness
and if I knew that adverse reactions
were a huge medical problem and
interactions between drugs was a huge
medical problem
and if I knew that 66 percent of the
people in the United States take
prescription medications and if I know
that interactions cause about 1.9
million emergency visits a year
and if I know finally that New Hampshire
Medicaid paid
150 million
912 dollars in prescription drugs
doesn't it make sense
that we tighten up
the looking at them
especially during Wellness advanced
therefore
I would vote Yes on this amendment thank
you
representative Weber is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I understand that
checking drug interactions is a very
important part of health care but I do
not want to mandate
a particular procedure preferring not to
intrude on a provider and patient
relationship
and further if I know that not only
Primary Care Providers but also
pharmacists look very carefully at the
issue of multiple drug uses and their
interactions would I now press the red
button to keep this particular provision
questions on the adoption of amendment
1901 H and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
representative
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attended the state of the
vote
167 in the affirmative 193 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative comtrust moves floor
Amendment 1909 H and representative
Sweeney requests to roll calls as
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded
so now though members take your seats
okay
the question is on the adoption of
amendment 1909 H and this is a roll call
vote representative comtrust was
thank you Mr Speaker
I know it's getting late folks but here
we are
Mr Speaker
if I know that when folks work for
something it means a lot more to them
and if I know that we should be helping
people get back to work that should be a
priority
and if I know that in this job market
there are several jobs
where they are looking for help
so all able-bodied citizens are able to
find jobs and Mr Speaker if I know the
taxpayers should not be supporting folks
volunteering
for places like Americans for Prosperity
or Moms on
Demand Action groups taxpayers
should be in the business Mr Speaker
of helping people and if I know
that government programs should be
giving a hand up
and not a hand out
would I now press the green button
thank you Mr Speaker
representative Weber's recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
remember
that we have already addressed the issue
of unemployment and work requirements
several times
and we have addressed the removal of the
transfer of funds from alcohol abuse and
treatment funds several times and by the
way this amendment apparently also
reduces the extension to two years would
I now vote red and who knew there was a
thank you
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1909 H and this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
thank you
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
163 in the affirmative 191 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative patenza moves floor
Amendment
1922 and guess what representative
and it is a sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
foreign
suits you H and this is a roll call vote
we're representative pretends is
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this amendment
which is
1922 H alcohol Abuse Prevention and
treatment fund is really a no-brainer
and if I know this amendment
uses
dedicated funds towards their intended
purpose
which is for Alcohol and Other Drug
Abuse Prevention treatment Recovery
Services and other purposes related to
the duties of the commission under RSA
12j3
and if I know it's not to be funneled
through New Hampshire Grant Advantage
Health Care Program
representative Weber is recognized for
if I know that we have addressed this
provision several times already and the
bill is still going to be referred to
finance to discuss funding and we are
here to discuss Health Care policy but
alcohol and drug abuse prevention and
treatment is Health Care
and
would I now press the red button
the questions on Amendment the adoption
of amendment 19 suits you H and this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
press the green button if you're opposed
press the red voting stations are open
law member's presence had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
160 in the affirmative 187 in the
representative Potenza moves floor
Amendment 1923 and representative
Sweeney requests a roll calls as
sufficiently seconded and it is this
will be a roll call vote members take
questions on the adoption of amendment
one two nine two three h and this is a
roll call vote
representative is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the state
of emergency Reform Bill has been placed
into the budget just like SB 263
and if I know we experience the shutdown
of our places of worship and next time
it could be Equity Health Care centers
for women and if I know we have an
urgent need for state of emergency
reform in New Hampshire to prevent abuse
of power Safeguard civil liberties
enhance legislative oversight Foster
Public participation
and adapt to evolving threats and
finally if I know we should send a
message to our constituents that we will
protect their rights in all times good
or bad then I would than would I vote
green on this amendment to Live Free or
Die Trying thank you
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that Senate Bill 263 unamended
is supported by a large Coalition of
organizations with direct interests in
promoting the health of granite Staters
and by countless individual Granite
Staters all of whom want us to vote on
this bill without extraneous amendments
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1923 H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
156 in the affirmative 198 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative Cushman moves floor
Amendment 1929 and representative
Sweeney requests a roll call
representative gagne was ahead of the
curve there as sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
clear
so normally we wait to go to the well on
when we call you but close enough this
time
that'll be fine
the question
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1929 h and this is a roll call
vote representative cushman's recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker and I apologize for coming up
too early
um Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment removes language that would
allow funds from the Liquor Commission
fund to be used in the event of
insolvency of the Granite Advantage
Medicaid trust fund
and if I also know that the Liquor
Commission fund serves as the financial
backbone for the entire Liquor
Commission which is responsible for the
maintenance and operation of our state
liquor stores including licensing
ensuring compliance with regulations and
purchasing
and Mr Speaker if I know that it that
this fund acts as a reserve fund for
employee salaries providing a safety net
should salary payment needs exceed the
allocated budget
and lastly Mr Speaker
if I know that voting yes on this
amendment would demonstrate our
commitment to responsible Financial
stewardship and the protection of our
state programs would I now press the
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
speaker
if I know that there
that the provision in the existing
program that
terminates the program if Federal
funding goes below its current 90
percent
and if I know that there will be further
opportunities to discuss funding issues
in the finance committee
would I press the red button
questions on the adoption of amendment
1929 H and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
foreign
wheeler
all members Presidents had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote
166 in the affirmative 190 and the
negative the amendment fails
representative Prout moves floor
Amendment
1787 H representative Sweeney requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
and it is this will be a roll call vote
foreign
questions on the adoption of 1789h and
this is a roll call vote representative
Crouch recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this amendment will add House
Bill 639 to this bill
the the version of the cannabis bill
sponsored by both of our party leaders
in this house
and if I know this house has already
passed the exact language of this
amendment
and if I know this house has passed many
versions of cannabis legalization only
to see them fail to be enacted into law
but if I know what this house has not
done is attach it to something important
something that cannot fail
and that is what I'm asking you to do
now
and if I know some may be worried that
this will cause Medicaid expansion to
fail
don't
we all know that it'll be extended
regardless of the vote on this amendment
it will not be allowed to expire
and if I believe the question before us
is
do you want to get legalized cannabis as
a potential bonus on the deal
and if I know I do would I now press the
I also be in order representative Weber
here if I am delighted to hear my friend
and colleague say that this bill is an
important bill which cannot fail
and if I also believe that the cannabis
bill that we worked on and passed was a
good bill
but I know that the Senate has already
defeated it
sorry
them thems as I may not mention have
already defeated it
and I know that the governor has
outlined the exact
parameters that he needs before he will
sign a cannabis bill and this bill is
not it
would I now press the red button so we
can vote on a clean bill on the granite
Advantage Program
questions on the adoption of amendment
1789 H and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red voting
[Music]
representative
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote I also attended the
state of the vote
118 in the affirmative 241 on the
negative the amendment fails
we are now on the main motion of ought
to pass
are you ready for the question all those
they got a division and enzymes will be
a division vote members please if you're
already in your seats right
division vote members please take your
seats
foreign
call
potential
as I sufficiently seconded it is this
question is on the main motion of ought
to pass on Senate Bill 263 and this is a
roll call vote representative Co Falls
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this body has
already passed Medicaid expansion with a
sunset provision
and if I know that Medicaid spending has
grown to over one-third of our state's
budget and continues to grow as a
and if I know that a program this big
this complex and this expensive deserves
a periodic review and reauthorization by
the people's elected representatives
and finally if I know that limiting
debate on this bill
and amendments
runs counter to the traditions of this
body and the sense of openness and
transparency that we strive for what I
then press the red button so that we can
hold to the version of Medicaid
expansion that has already passed this
chamber by a wide margin
thank you Mr Speaker
representative Weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
three unamended
is supported by a large Coalition of
organizations with direct interest in
promoting the health of granite Staters
and by countless individual Granite
Staters
and if I know that Senate Bill 263
unamended promotes Access to Health Care
a healthy Workforce reduces
uncompensated care and cost shifting
I also be in order
questions on the motion of ought to pass
on Senate Bill 263 and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
I also attended the state of the vote
193 on the affirmative 166 and the
and the bill is referred to the
for what reason does a member rise uh I
move that we put the remarks of the
debate on SB 263 and all the amendments
important without without it
there will be okay
and
uh
and our division has been called
the motion before us
is to print the Reeboks
of the last debate in the permanent
Journal
if you're in favor of that there's a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposed
or press the red button voting stations
[Music]
fall members president had the
opportunity to vote house will
172 voting a 178 voting a
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne
without objection the four bills taken
off the consent calendar will be brought
chair recognize the member from Auburn
representative Osborne for the third
reading motion
hey it resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that they're
reading of bills will be by title only
in resolutions by caption only and that
all bills are ordered a third reading be
read a third time by this resolution and
that all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today A B to meet at the call of the
chair
still get a couple of things to do
the question is on the third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay you guys have it the
motion is adopted
we have two announcements
uh chair recognized representative D
Simone
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you all
I'll make this quick uh the owls
thank you we'll meet at a lunchtime
meeting in the Webster room the next
session day bring your lunch
everyone man and woman are you're all
invited it's a reorganization meeting I
look forward to seeing you all
do you recognize representative Wilder
from
announcement
thank you Mr Speaker
the house will be in order for a minute
for the Masons of Lodge
General Court Lodge 1784 we will not be
meeting tonight we'll aim for next June
on the day we have the pictures June
representative Osmond Moon that the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills and World build
amendments and Road Bill report and
receiving messages
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
what is the post nay the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted the house is
okay